Hey, why why they got to bite the dick, though? Can you tell
me that? What medical condition does it help when you bite the
dick? Tell me why they bite the dick, Connor. Just tell me explain
why they bite the dick, Connor. That's all you got to do. One
sec. I have to go figure out what the [__] just fell
in my house. Holy [__] Something so loud just banged
like in my house. If I get I miss you guys or I'll miss you guys,
okay? If somebody's here, they they really did find me. Oh boy,
hold on. Okay, who's getting sock puppeted? How On what basis
are you to say What What don't I say you're getting sock puppeted
by the the tea light Yarvinite class of techno fascist or the
>> I'm being ripped by a tiger right now, Pisco. I I I
I'm being s- by a giant tiger.
>> Fairly, Pisco Counter-Points talked and I think this
might be fun cuz I could probably steal back Counter-Points.
I think a lot of people are
I think a lot of people feel like Counter-Points is a white nationalist
and I
I think he's just poor. He does a very poor job of expressing
himself. I think I haven't seen it yet, so we'll see. Oh, let's
see the Connor bit
is right here. Is this the start of the >> Yours is happy
New Year. This is where this starts to get heated. >> Oh,
this is the start of the conversation. Okay, cool cool cool cool
>> I just have one question for you, though, first before
we get started.
Why are you cultivating a community of snarkers in your community?
What? Because I don't police them enough. Yeah, so don't you
think that you have an obligation to moderate your
No.
Hey, what are you talking about? You don't actually believe this.
I don't know if you missed it, Swipebants freedom. I'm pretty
sure I'm just going to pull the trigger that Pisco did and ban
all Destiny drama from my Discord.
Cuz it's not worth the allegations.
It's not worth people getting super It's not worth it. It's literally
not worth it. >> Wait, hold on. No, I So so sorry. The
real answer is I don't think the people in my chat actually really
are snarkers. >> I don't know. Just answer this very simple
question. How much has Doobie super chatted you in the last 3
months, would you say?
$1,500 in what? You think he's just doing that for no reason?
No, he's doing that because he wants me to agree with >> Haven't
you ever like stood back and thought about why these people are
congregating in your community?
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, so why do you think that's happening?
Does Connor not see what he's doing? I Do people care? Is anti-drama
DGG is so Yeah, I wonder why the policy has changed entirely,
Swipebants. There are people who want me to come over to the
J Star side. They want me to disavow Destiny. Why you call it
my side? It's literally the side of the people Again,
I'll talk to literally If I trusted a moderator, I would probably
talk to I would I would probably talk to Destiny directly. But
I I just don't trust that he'll ever be good faith in any conversation.
He's just going to sperg and I don't want to deal with it. But
I'm talking to somebody else, like literally anybody else who
has all the facts He feels like they have all the facts. I'll
talk to anybody about this. Like I just know that I have the
correct
But I'm not going to make a big deal out of it anymore. I'm just
I'm not I'm We're moving on, okay?
Destiny say he's a piece of [__]
You know, say that he manages his personal affairs terribly,
that he's abrasive and abusive and emotionally callous and a
reptile and this that and the other. And so as a result there
those people do exist and some of them some of them donate, some
of them don't. You understand these people are literally responsible
for some of the most like deranged stalking behavior that you
would ever seen in any community, right?
That these people like will go to lengths to dox and attack people's
families. They are horrible people that you're allowing to fester
in your >> I think you would have to bring up individuals
because the only person the only I've had uh Rile Kinch house
on stream where we had a
uh tough conversation and then Doobie hangs out, but I don't
really know of any other people besides Doobie who don't like
There's people who don't like Destiny, but they don't like Destiny,
but I don't think they engage in that kind of >> chat,
dude. I I've seen parts of your chat where people are saying
all sorts of crazy sh- crazy sh- And if that sh- was in my chat
about you, you know I'd be moderating
I'm not telling you I'm not I'm not I'm not thought exercise
what do you Yeah, I I assume
If I were Connor, like the second Pisco started this, I'd just
be like, "Wait, do you want to discuss how like this allegation
could be levied at anybody? Cuz like I agree with you that it's
kind of cooked." I just wouldn't want to I just wouldn't want
to have this like weird pantomime go on for much longer. It just
feels >> you I'm not telling you to ban anybody. I'm not
telling you but why why haven't you moderated that? Why is your
community like that? I'm just asking you to give me an answer.
Th- This This feels like a thought exercise, not an actual conversation.
>> asking why you are cultivating snarkers. Why are you
allowing snarkers into your community? You know these people
are responsible for for lying and bullying
N- Yeah, number one, it's funny. Uh number two, so so hold on.
So for the sake of this conversation because I don't know if
we're going to wrap and this is going to be like a metaphorical
point or if you're act- if we're actually going to continue with
this line of conversation
Pisco, no, Moon Rey Murray.
Pisco is doing a joke where he is expressing
that
obviously the way that people were trying to attack him could
essentially be weaponized against anybody.
Right? It could be weaponized against literally anyone. Anyone
who like Doobie donates to cuz he decided he like
wants to I don't know what do I don't know why Doobie gives money,
to be honest with you. He just can, okay?
So Pisco's just He's just around and saying like, "Why are you
doing the exact same thing? Like literally differentiate Pisco
from Connor in terms of how the chats interact, right?"
It's The difference is on a personal level on a personal level
Connor agrees with Destiny, right? >> for the next 5 to
10 minutes. Are we going to continue with this line of conversation
for the next 5 to 10 minutes? 5 minutes. >> Cuz I'll I'll
answer it earnestly. I don't care. >> it earnestly.
Okay, I This got presented to me as if Pisco was serious here
and while he may be acting serious for the sake of like making
the point, this isn't like a serious thing that he would do that
he's like very serious about anyway,
>> relatively pretty pro free speech uh perspective in
my chat. Matter of fact, you can be a You can be a piece of [__]
You can hate Destiny. You can have a different take on the Red
Sea crisis. You can like Hasan [__] The one thing
that will actually get you banned super quick in my chat is being
a smug [__] That's like that's like the fastest way.
>> So so if people are making People are making in in If
people If people are making insane accusations to people, you
don't moderate that? You don't think you have duty to moderate
that and ban these
You You'd have to give me an example because even with >> Why
Why would I have to do that? Well, I I don't I don't I don't
watch He should hit Connor with the What, you want me to You
want me to like have a link for you right now? We're having a
conversation. Why would I have a link right now?
>> You want me to have evidence for my claims? Why Why
would I want to have Why would I have evidence for my claims?
>> all right. B- B- People know. People I mean, come on.
People tell me. I think the biggest guy who dislikes
There There's a couple of grapers who dislike Steven.
I think that Doobie is the only person who makes points about
Steven and some of the points he makes >> And you let him
stay on there, right? You So you You let Doobie stay in your
community?
Okay, why why are you Why should you do
Well, I mean, if Steven wants to donate
then I'll ban Doobie. That's it? It's just money for you? It's
not cultivating a community of horrible snarkers. >> entertaining.
Oh, okay. That's
How would you ban him for $1,501?
That's all it takes and then That's like that's what I have like
a pretty principled position against banning people a lot of
the time, okay? Like like literally taking money, at least maybe
most I guess mostly for on-stream participants. I got offered
a lot of money to ban people a lot of times and I'm like, "Nah.
Good. No, thank you." >> Do you Do you Do you think you
fulfilled a good standard of moderation? Yeah, I I I relatively
speaking like freedom of speech and freedom of conscience. Actually,
you know what? I've had a change of heart, Connor. I agree with
you. I think that I also like cultivate communities with free
expression and open dialogue and I largely think that that's
like okay to do and I don't think it means that you're intentionally
cultivating a community of snarkers. What do you think about
that? Uh I I literally Pisco could have just said like, "You
think Destiny's like being totally deranged about me, right?"
And Connor would have probably just gone, "Yeah, I think he's
like kind of losing his mind."
I I think they He could have just gone and He did this whole
thing.
And I think he could have just gone like, "You understand You
You think Destiny's being like totally deranged about me and
my community, right?" And Connor probably just go, "Yeah, I think
so." Oh, sorry. Yeah, I think that's fine. I I think the guilt
by association stuff is cringe and Okay, this is this is wrong.
Pisco is not a theater kid. This is different than theater kid.
This was This was like math club president. >> We used
to criticize the [__] out of guilt by association
a few years ago. Sure. So do you have any problem with my moderation
style?
No. As a matter of fact, I think your moderation style is looser
than my moderation style. Oh, really? >> you tolerate you
tolerate more [__] at least as far as I understand.
There are people Connor
Connor is being nice here to Pisco and Pisco thinks that Connor's
making a point about how Pisco like allows or something in a
way Connor doesn't. Connor's probably just saying that like if
people attack me personally, if they annoy me personally, I ban
them, but you like are really patient. >> you off to the
point that I would have just banned them. Like like if somebody's
being like a smug snarky And I'm not even saying snark like a
drama frog who hates somebody else. I mean snark as in like they
have this holier-than-thou attitude. A holier-than-thou attitude
despite me having it. I'm the streamer. You're the chatter. If
you're acting holier-than-thou, you're getting [__]
banned. So and I think you tolerate those people at least as
far as what I've seen. Sure. I know. I I completely all right.
I'm going to level with you, Connor. I was being a a bit facetious
when I just uh and No way.
interrogated you there. I figured. It sounded exactly
like the line of argumentation that has been used against you
for still being tepidly friendly with people who dislike Steven.
No. No. No.
Pisco literally Pisco literally doesn't talk to me.
I don't like try to force my By the way, I also think it's like
cringe to try to like insinuate yourself. I was in Pisco's Discord.
I didn't say anything until Pisco was gone. When I was in that
one call that happened in Pisco's Discord that people posted
screenshots of to Twitter. I didn't even say anything. No, I
don't think you should reference that here. Yeah, well, it depends
on friendly friendly with people who dislike Steven. Uh yeah,
well, it depends on who you're talking about. There are some
people who are with who That's not even That wouldn't even be
Aaron. I don't think Aaron Has Aaron talked [__]
about Destiny in public ever? I'm pretty sure like I I've never
talked to Aaron about this cuz uh
I don't think I get the impression
I don't even want to say anything.
Never mind. I don't think she's ever made any public commentary.
>> I'm friends with who I think dislike Steven, but guess
what? No, I was just going to No, I wasn't going to say anything
like secret. It's just like I get the impression that they literally
don't want they don't want the heat. They don't want to have
like people hating on them, like her and Lycan, so they just
don't talk about any of it. Like they explicitly like if she
if she's in a conversation where it's happening, she doesn't
talk about it. If she'll leave if it goes on for long enough,
and I I've never seen Lycan comment on Destiny ever. I think
they don't want any part of it, and I didn't want to say that
in a way that made it seem like I'd heard them talk [__]
and I knew that It's more like I just know I just know that
Wait, everybody knows that it's a Wait, hold on. Is it a viable
strategy though, Kilo? Is it a viable strategy? I don't think
it is. I think it's basically like um the Mad King is a good
example, or like Darth Vader. It's like I've altered Literally,
you haven't been talking about me, Aaron? Well, actually, you're
the worst person ever, and I can't believe they let you off the
hook.
Like okay, well, cool. >> There He is friends with people
who don't like me, and you have friends who don't like me, and
I have friends who don't like you. And guess what? That's called
human society. That's called like we're living all in a society.
Now, if there are people who are using your communities to do
illegal or TOS stuff or that violate your rules, I'm sure you
have and will moderate that, won't you?
Yeah, absolutely.
By the way,
I think if most people adopted
the standard of I'm I'm like not going to disavow this person
or move away from them, but I will describe their behavior accurately.
If most people were operating on that standard, like I'm going
to describe the situation accurately, I wouldn't really have
a problem. I'd have no problem with that. Wouldn't bug me at
all.
It's the like lying stuff that gets them on my nerves. >> Matter
of fact, the thing that uh Steven was talking about as far as
like the the worst things that have happened to him, doxxing,
swatting,
IRL harassment,
digital harassment, emails, all that kind of stuff, those would
be the fastest way If somebody told me and showed me some evidence
that somebody in my community had done that stuff, that's the
fastest way that they're going to get banned. Uh just as an example
though, I would We're now on the level where people are acting
like a single cold email is a level of harassment where you have
to ban somebody
We're on that That's where we've arrived at, okay? The single
cold email, spamming people's doxx on Twitter, not not that level
of harassment. We don't ban those people. A single cold email,
um that person needs to be banned, and those people all need
to be like rejected from any of these other communities.
of your friends and co-workers? No, no, no, no, no, no, no. That's
fine. Without their consent No, no, no, no, no. That's not That's
not a violation. Single cold
nuke that guy. Nuke that guy now. will bring this up. There's
the send
I don't think anybody has a problem with the emails to Rosevarine.
Or at least they don't if they're saying it's the emails to the
other people that are involved, like the family, right? Hi Seida,
Sepa, whatever that guy's name is who emailed that girl's family.
Even if on principle I thought that Steven should, you know,
figure out his civil case, how whatever reason, like, you know,
may maybe he's done some wrong things there. On principle, I
would view that as touching the poo, and I would ban Sepa or
Seida or whatever that guy's name is. Oh, for off off platform
conduct.
Yeah, I mean, because if that if that's what he's willing to
do, where he's willing to touch the poo proverbially, I don't
want him touching the poo in my community's name. Well, I think
that
perhaps a certain
Pisco shouldn't Pisco shouldn't even have these conversations
if he doesn't want to litigate it. Cuz you you have to actually
litigate it to have a real conversation, right? >> line
of people um that it would make sense to preemptively ban. Um
if you are someone, for example, let's say that you don't want
to wade into those kinds of issues, because you've you've [clears throat]
said before that, you know, there are good reasons why you shouldn't
do that. I think that you would agree if given that profile.
I think they're basically
the basis you have to come from to to believe the like narrative
about Cybah. The basis you have to come from is that it's like
evil that Destiny is being
That you have to be at the place where it's evil that Destiny
is being sued, any pursuit of that case is evil, because Cybah
did nothing harmful that wouldn't have been carried out by a
PI. I understand that people want the oversight there. I understand
that people don't trust him, and I don't think you should trust
somebody who like is willing to reach out from an online community
to someone in real life, but there was no harm done here. And
we can evaluate and understand that there was no harm done.
That this isn't harm beyond what like a private investigator
would have inflicted trying to find the same people the same
ways.
Right? Um which in Pisco Destiny debate Destiny said it wasn't
wrong for Pisco Pixie to sue him. Yeah. Now, I think I think
it's crazy again. I I personally don't want people doing that.
It's a hard red line now. You do that [__] in this
community, it's an auto ban. Like I said, because of I was preoccupied,
I didn't get a chance to look into it for a while. I didn't know
exactly how stuff went down.
and then Destiny doxx the guy. I'm like, well, it feels like
you got punished for this. I feel like I don't want to then say
also you can't be in this community where you spend time now
Right? That was how I That was how I felt about it. You might
not like that. I understand you might not like that. Um but again,
I just don't I think this is a situation I don't want to repeat
itself. And now maybe looking at further I guess policies in
the Discord. We'll see. someone who doesn't want to wade into
those substantive issues, perhaps, that to preemptively ban on
the basis of wading into those issues would sort of counter the
whole point of that person's stance. That's right. But I'm
So, Pisco Pisco's saying I don't want to Oh, he actually just
said but Oh,
yeah, exactly.
That Pisco it's going to be hard for Pisco to have an opinion
on whether or not to ban Cybah unless he weighs in unless he
actually goes and figures it out to litigate it in his own head
what happened. That if he doesn't want to look into it, he can
give you the discretion of not looking into it and not giving
his opinion, but he can't also just take somebody's word for
it and ban somebody. That's how he feels.
And that would be weird for him to say I don't want to comment
on it, but also wade into it and ban somebody based on like one
side's interpretation of the I'm not sure if I fully understand
you, but the uh I
Yeah, actually, could you say it again if you want me to understand
it, because I'm not sure if I understand it. Assume that like
there were
there were a set of issues that you had for responsible reasons
chosen not to get into, and the only basis to pre- Dude, a dude,
am I the only person who understands
I WHY DO I UNDERSTAND Pisco perfectly when he speaks? I never
misunderstand this guy, and then a whole bunch of people are
like, wait, what did you say? What huh?
Wait, you just said something crazy. Wait, what? >> preemptively
ban a person were to be to wade into those issues and make it
some kind of disposition on those issues. That to do so would
itself be wading into issues in which you've been taking a principled
stance not to get involved. You follow that? Oh, yeah. This This
is actually one of the things that happened during the Mr. Girl
drama in 2022 where I actually agreed with Steven on. Uh I think
a house is a man's castle. I think a man's chat is a man's castle
castle. I think a man's Discord and Reddit is a man's castle,
and therefore, if there is a topic that somebody is repeatedly
dragging towards, and it's something that you want to avoid as
a community or as a
>> Doobie be trolling with big money for some reason. >> peatedly
dragging towards, and it's some I Do I need to start streaming
in the morning to afternoon just for just
so Doobie can watch?
>> Is there Is there Is there big enough market in Doobie
donations that like streaming in the afternoon is the way to
go? I think I got to stream like 8 hours sooner, okay? Just just
so Doobie is awake and active. >> thing that you want I'm
getting the feeling that he watches streams at work. >> to
avoid as a community or as a streamer, then yeah, you're you're
a king. You you you know, I I tell my mods all the time, uh you
know, if there's somebody who's pissing me off, I'm like, mods,
twist his balls, and then those people get banned. Well, I I
just want to say um that I respect your position here. It doesn't
sound like you have any problem with how I'm cultivating my community.
I, however, am I'm I'm taking a look at um you know, potential
issues, and so people say things to me. And so, if there are
DGG mods who want to apply to be a mod in my community, I welcome
their applications. I'm in In fact, I'm I'm taking the time to
go and seek out some mods myself.
And if they would like to uh join the modding team Did he not
have enough DGG mods already?
I'm just No offense, but like as far as I understand, a lot of
those people were already DGGers.
What do we need?
Sorry. Did Actually, better question. Does he have a single mod
that wasn't a DGGer?
I think he's making fun of them. Oh, maybe. Maybe.
entertain their applications to do so to see what great and wonderful
suggestions they can bring to the moderation team
My my beef with your community actually or my beef with your
content so to speak
Can we get some Starkers to go and apply to be mods in Pisco's
Discord? We need Stark representation in Pisco's Disc Missy,
apply now. Missy, apply now. >> something that makes your
content more entertaining,
but it's effectively like I think that you and the liberals or
whatever are playing footsie with
who should be ultimately like yelled at and screamed at and bullied
out of public life, but you know, you doing those things makes
the content more interesting. So, we we disagree.
Uh I think that you should take a pro-leftist
bullying stance,
uh but then I get to bully you about not bullying the leftist.
>> Yeah, but I I don't understand what you're talking about
I don't understand what you're talking about. Like I play footsie,
but you're just talking about Mom Donny AOC. That's That's all
the things you're talking about. >> Donny AOC Don't say
it's on Paik.
>> Wait, so you must have condemned Ro Khanna. Did I hear
you say it? Yeah, I mean I I've said that I like Ro Khanna for
XYZ ABC, but I also don't like him for XYZ. >> you talking
about? He just had a sit-down with Hasan [__] Did
you see it? Or did you miss that? >> condemned that. [__]
him for that. Oh, but you might still support him. That's his
second one.
You hypocrites. You hypocrite. You hypocrite. There No, there
is no there is no through line into what you're talking about
here. You will take issue with me hanging out with the Vanguard
on Live and Learn when they're coming in and being grilled by
Hutch and me actually opposing them, but when Ro Khanna has a
session with Hasan [__] you're like, "Oh, I'll condemn
that." You're such a hypocrite on this. I'm dead serious.
I'll say it. I'll say God damn it. I don't I don't want to be
like hard on Connor.
But the boy's got a flexible spine, okay? He's got a very flexible
spine.
He He doesn't really stand on almost anything. Yeah, he doesn't
have principles. He's got mostly vibes.
Mostly vibes, mostly vibes. I don't know. It is what it is, man.
Ro Khanna on that On that. On that. But you don't But you don't
Is he in the way I am? Probably. I haven't watched the content.
[laughter] Oh, holy sh- Do you think he went on there on Hasanabi's
podcast and was more combative than I was with Vanguard and with
Hutch there on Live and Learn? No, I doubt it. But But hold on,
let me actually articulate a sentence so we can get past memes.
Yeah. So, I'm not memeing. This is That the the previous part
wasn't a meme. This is real. I don't think that you have any
good standing that you're applying here. I think that you're
you're going harder on me than people Yeah.
So, it's the same way with Thomas Massie, okay? Thomas Massie
was Ro Khanna and Thomas Massie are both the authors of the Epstein
bill. The whole reason why we are absolutely as a
coalition
annihilating
the Trump administration is because of legislation that was authored
and pushed through by Ro Khanna and Thomas Massie. And so, in
that degree, they have my support. However, Thomas Massie is
also like a schizophrenic
fiscal conservative who legitimately believes in chemtrails.
He thinks chemtrails are a thing. He's almost as crazy as Marjorie
Taylor Green. And so, he doesn't have my support in that regard.
>> Yeah, but if it was Thomas Massie if it was Thomas Massie
versus Ro Khanna for president, who would you vote for? Yeah,
Thomas Massie all day. Yeah, so then what good is this? What
good is this [__]
You're You're basically suggesting that someone who believes
in chemtrails more than I like socialists or social democrats,
yeah. It's Ro Khanna. He is in a tech [__] utopia
over there in capitalist
Then he should stop playing footsie with socialists and then
maybe he'll get my
I mean, isn't Ro Khanna basically a socialist? Ro Khanna is like
super progressive in a super progressive district trying to get
the tax rate increased in California.
Wait, what is he I don't know what I guess I don't know broadly
what his politics are. Why is he the politician most engaged
with progressive victory?
Sorry, I tend to think progressive and leftist are pretty closely
aligned. He is a lizard. Um translation, Forane says he is a
lizard. He tepidly occasionally shows some level of support for
Israel.
That's what he's >> Maybe your read on this podcast circuit
Maybe that's what's Maybe you're unable to distinguish when a
candidate is using someone
where they have a leftist travel to an authoritarian nation that
I would say has arguably demons- demonstrated such morally egregious
behavior that they're comparable to Nazi Germany before the Holocaust
was discovered and you guys are playing footsie with the guy.
But the the thing is the the problem is though, Connor, maybe
your analysis would hold weight if it were a democrat that was
sent there instead of Hasan [__] going there. And
maybe it would work if the democrats, I don't know, was part
of this like long-standing bipartisan consensus against China.
And I don't know if it weren't Joe Biden all the democrats who
signed on to a bipartisan TikTok ban for the sole purpose of
trying to stymie influence from allegedly from China. You know,
some people have their other conspiracy theories about why the
TikTok ban was was put into place, but I would maybe take your
criticism more seriously if it was, I don't know, tailored to
democrats as opposed to Hasan [__] But the conflation
between them never stops for you, does it? Dude, if I if I had
a a map because they they do this with like Jeffrey Epstein and
Donald Trump.
Bro, Pisco can't be this stupid. Oh, I was looking at something
off screen for a second. Do I have to go back and see what he
said? What was he What was Pisco just saying? Hold on, let me
let me absorb this whole thing. >> ban was was put into
They've They've openly talked about banning TikTok for Israel.
Oh, no. No, Joe Biden was banning it because of Chinese concerned
about Chinese influence.
This was already being talked about
um before October 7th.
Like banning like the concerns about data privacy with regards
to ByteDance having control over all that data. That they didn't
think the like separation between ByteDance and like US-backed
entities was strong.
And it failed?
I thought the TikTok ban was absolutely I mean, that was the
pretense for it 100%. Nothing about Israel on there. It failed
and then the Israel The Israel lobby came in. I need a link to
see this. I don't believe it. >> place, but I would maybe
I don't believe that because why did Donald Trump keep TikTok
up multiple times when it was just like the Israel lobby who
wanted it taken down?
Why wouldn't Trump
Zion Don himself
let it just let that order just go through? Why did he keep canceling
it? Why did he keep delaying
You tell me Zion Don went against Big Bad Ben? Maybe take your
criticism more seriously if it was, I don't know, tailored to
democrats as opposed to Hasan [__] But the conflation
between them never stops for you, does it? Dude, if I if I had
a a map because they they do this with like Jeffrey Epstein and
Donald Trump. It would be like a red line directly from one character
to another character, okay? So, saying, "How dare you? My pearls,
I must clutch them. How dare you associate the Democratic Party
with the extremities of Hasan Piker's rhetoric?" >> It's
something you don't do. We know No, because No, no, no, no, it's
No, because
AOC, Bernie
What about the line between
J.D. Vance and
Oh, man. Like you could find the most anti-Semitic person like
I I wanted to say somebody el- other than Fuentes, but like yeah,
J.D. Vance and Fuentes. J.D. Vance uses a ton of Fuentes rhetoric.
They've all been using a ton of Fuentes
That's a one the one red line. You should get Connor to double
down cuz I think Connor says this. A lot of people say this.
Oh, Hasan's way worse than Nick Fuentes. Hasan's like wait what
Dude, what happened to these people?
Like if you're going to talk about harmful rhetoric
My god. >> it's such garbage.
No, it's such It's such [__] garbage. No, so So,
YOU DON'T YOU DON'T DO IT FOR
You don't You don't do it for DeSantis. You don't do it for DeSantis.
You don't do it to Vance. You're considering No, you [__]
don't. Not with any bass in your voice. Not with any bass in
your voice. You don't do it for them. That's what these entire
conversations have been >> conservatarians
more than I like socialists. Shocking for a Republican.
>> No, but you what you're suggesting is a direct through
line to policy makers. This is Trump in the White House. Trump
with control over the government. Trump with control a lot of
exercising control over the ideology of his base where it's clearly
top-down from one direction. What's that direction? MAGA. Comparing
to some democrats who are using Hasan's platform to spread their
message and their agenda and who are taking his audience and
clearly extracting from him. You are comparing those two relationships
and saying, "I'm more troubled by a podcast appearance." By the
way, we've already had this argument three times. So, I don't
know if I want to have it again. >> Okay, all right. All
right. I thought you were going to I thought you were going to
come
and you were going to say, "Oh, man, I disagree with your characterization."
Well, I guess you you're not watching the content, which is fine.
It's fine. >> Well, I I do sometimes. I was I was [__]
around with that. I do sometimes. But I was um What was it? I
was just watching CF Young and Destiny fight over Nick Fuentes
and whether or not liberalism has failed and then also fighting
about like the historical support for the Zionist vision of Israel.
So that that's what I thought we were going to fight about, but
that's okay. >> Oh, no, no. You want You think I'm going
to fight you about about Israel with
I mean, we could if you wanted to. Matter of fact, I have a drawing.
Do you want to see my drawing?
Finish what you're going to say and then we'll get into your
drawing. Yeah. So anyway, Do you want to see my drawing? I made
a drawing. Do you want to see my drawing?
I made a I made a drawing. Do you want to see my drawing? Do
you want to see it? I I made a cool drawing. Like do you want
to see my drawing? Guys, the what what I've argued previously,
which I still think is true, is that >> Oh my goodness.
This Connor guy. >> excuses in order to justify their relationships
with crazy people. But what happened was the crazy people were
so powerful and so clouded up because they got hooked into the
mainstream that as a result, they started to have to listen to
the crazy people. And that's how we've ended up where we we we've
ended up. And what's happening is I don't see that as extreme
on the left wing, but whenever I bring it up in reference to
the left wing, you say, "Oh, no, no, no. We're doing exactly
what MAGA did 10 years ago, but we're
>> built different. We're not going to fall into the trap."
And I think it's pretty stupid. I think it's stupid. I I think
that you just see Trump and Hasan as the same kind of figure
with the same kind of influence that they have and you're seeing
this like spectre that isn't a
It is not a threat. Okay, I I think tens of Okay, is Hasan [__]
yes or no, is he the largest political alt media political commentator
in the Western world? No.
Who's bigger? Asmongold's bigger. Okay.
That's actually true. Yeah. Is Is this
Fuentes and Candace are both bigger, too, and Tucker >> number
two.
I don't know. He's up there. Okay, he's up there. Anyways, let's
let's just put it in the top five. There actually there's a bunch
of conservatives who are above Hasan. I've top 10 or whatever.
Tens of thousands or hundreds of thousands of people
simultaneously believing that advocating for social democratic
policy and also that you should sweep for all the authoritarian
socialist regimes of the 20th century is repulsive to me. Okay?
Disgusting.
This would be like, I don't know, the Republican Party cozying
up to It would be something like that. So the fact Do you understand
that the fight right now in the Republican Party is No, I mean,
that's the fight, right? Because we did what I'm warning you
>> Yeah. And the You know what the fight is on the Democrat
Party? What's the fight right now? Kamala Harris versus Gavin
Newsom versus [__] Josh Shapiro. That's the fight
among Democrats.
Yeah, but dude You always do this thing like liberals and Democrats
always do this thing where they're like, "When when we're not
talking about these characters being like large in the zeitgeist,
we're so uwu, we're so cute, we're so kawaii, we're so small.
Why are you even attacking the socialists this that the other?"
And then when the socialists do something that's huge, you're
like, >> What have they done that's huge? What What power
do they have? What power do they have? >> these excuses
for it. What power do they What power do they have? Mondani has
endorsed Hakeem Jeffries. Mondani is building a relationship
with Kathy
Mondani is going to work within the And he's the best you got.
And he's not a [__] He's not a tankie. He's not a
>> poisonous. And if Mondani governed the way that he was
tweeting in 2019,
I was going to say, I do think you should acknowledge that Mondani
seemed to be like a pretty die-in-the-wool socialist in his earlier
political >> And if this was the Vietnam War, He'd govern
like He'd govern like Karen Bass. He He would govern like any
Karen Bass. He would govern govern like any one of these other
Democrats who when they went very very very woke and far to left,
they I need caffeine so badly. Hold on. I need I need caffeine
super badly right now. Hopefully they get to the white supremacist
stuff, the Connor Kreiper
connection, okay? But I need caffeine cuz I'm falling asleep.
I'm barely commenting, okay?
It's crazy. Give me um 45 seconds. pummeled in the next election
even by their own Democrats. They were you know, elections you
know, taking them out of office for some of the allegations and
[__] and accusations and fuckups. >> it's it's
the same analogy. Unfortunately, we've already had this conversation.
So if you want to have it again, we can, but I do find it a little
>> All right, all right, all right. It It The analogy,
which I I I said last time we talked about this, it's like having
a house cat that you just feed over and over again and depending
on how much you feed it is how big it gets. Right now, I see
you guys feeding a house cat and you say, "Hey, it's a house
cat. Don't worry about it." But what I'm saying is that if you
keep feeding this house cat, it's going to become the size of
a tiger and it's going to eat your [__] face. And
you're like, "Well, what's your evidence that if I continue to
feed this house cat, uh it's going to eat my [__]
face?" Meanwhile, I'm over here Well, so that's already That
analogy already a priori rules out the idea that the house cat
could have things that improve your life. That the house like
the house cat by definition in this example isn't giving you
a lot of utility, right? Like it's already The whole conversation
is about how much utility you get from like the socialist people.
It's not like that Oh, he's trying to argue that like communism
is killing people. Communism would kill people if we try to do
straight up like
like straight up
I'm trying to think whatever they implemented in China under
Mao, okay?
That's what he's trying to say, but it's like, "Okay, but there
are socialist ideas. There are flaws There's a philosophy, right?
There are ideas there that are helpful.
There are policies there that might be good. I don't mind having
conversations with these people. They're popular with people
for a reason. So we should be able to talk to them. You're saying
house cat. That that analogy already rules out the idea that
by feeding this house cat, it will help me in some way. And you're
saying, "Well, if you feed it too much, it might hurt you, too."
And I'm like, "Yeah, okay. Sure. Yeah, sure. Then it could hurt
me, too.
But I think how it would help more than hurt right now. So I
want to do that. And a tiger is wrapping its bladed teeth around
my throat. And you're like, "Not the NOT THE TABBY CAT. NOT THE
TABBY CAT."
DON'T GET EATEN BY THE TIGER. I I I LOVE YOUR I LOVE your analogy,
right? So So I love your Your Your analogy is so perfect. Your
Your analogy is so perfect, right? Cuz So guys, listen to Connor's
analogy cuz it actually is for for once perhaps. We'll look at
this drawing. For once, Connor's analogy is great.
Dude, okay. For all the [__] we give Hutch about
the faces he made,
I got to call I think Pisco's a little condescending, a little
patronizing with Connor sometimes.
Now, is that justified? Maybe. But if he's your friend, you should
try to chill on being like pretty openly patronizing, giggling
at this guy when you say, "We'll look at your drawing a little
bit later."
>> I'm just I'm just saying
if we do yell at Hutch for for making the faces, it's what good
friends do. Hutch undeserved smugness, true.
I'm just saying That was a particular kind of condescending that
I'm like,
I'd But if if Connor picked it up, he's I think he's okay. Connor,
I think I'm kind of like Connor in that way that if people like
take shots at me, it's like I I'm comfortable with who I am.
I don't have to I don't even have to respond. I'm good.
I think Connor's kind of like me in that way. So if he caught
that, he's not even concerned about responding apparently. >> For once
perhaps. We'll look at this drawing. But for once, Connor's analogy
is great. There's a tiger around his throat and you are over
there petting a kitten. He's like, "PLEASE, PLEASE STOP PETTING
THE KITTEN."
THAT'S A GREAT ANALOGY, CONNOR. TIGER AND I DON'T WANT TO
I'M PUNCHING I'M PUNCHING this tiger in the eye sockets repeatedly
as it's Hey. Now all Connor has to do is resolve the fact that
when Pisco says, "Okay, but like would you vote for like the
tabby cat or the tiger?" Connor's with the with the teeth around
his neck, he goes, "YEAH, I THINK THAT TABBY CAT WOULD BE BETTER
THAN KAMALA HARRIS."
OKAY? I actually choked myself to say that for you so you could
hear it, okay? That's Now he has to resolve that. He has to figure
out how to make that make sense to everybody he's talking to,
okay? Cuz I don't know how he does it. mauling my throat And
you're like, "Not the kitten. Not the kitten." No. No, no, no.
But But you're like you're like, "Hey, I'm going to make another
tiger for you to fight 5 to 10 years from now." Do you think
fighting one tiger is fun? Do you know what's even better than
one tiger? Two tigers. So I'm going to make another one for you
to fight. You want You want to know the difference about this
cat? This cat has one leg. It
the cat version of
I don't want to say it. It's a low IQ cat. >> feline A.
Is that rule two? Is that a rule two cat? It's very If we're
Wait, hold on. Wait, did he say >> It's a low IQ cat. feline
A. It's a very beautiful one It's Everyone loves the cat, but
the cat's not going to be a tiger, all right? It's a tabby cat.
It comes as a cat. And the other one's a tiger and it's eating
you. >> legs and it's got HIV. Put it down. Stop petting
it. Okay, then how about we worry about the tiger that's attacking
I AM WORRIED ABOUT THE TIGER. I'M PUNCHING IT IN THE EYES AND
JAMMING MY THUMB INTO ITS EYE HOLES. That's what I do all day.
But you're But you're also scratching the back of the other tiger
right behind it that's also a fully grown tiger. And you're like,
"Please save me from the little cat."
Well, that's that's because power abhors a vacuum.
>> Yeah, yeah. I don't know what that Yeah, okay. Well,
No, I got that means All right, show me your drawing. Israel-Palestine
[__] There's good There's good tigers Power abhors
a vacuum. What is that? Power Power abhors a vacuum.
Where is that said? Nature abhors a vacuum is something from
Spinoza. Power abhors a vacuum quote. Power abhors a vacuum.
Something around Milton
Ronald Reagan. Okay. You create a vacuum and as the old saying
goes, power abhors a vacuum. Ralph Nader. Okay, some Apparently
this is said a lot. I
I was like
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. This is what I was thinking, too.
Okay. That was That was where my brain first went. What 40K book
is this said? There's tigers that will eat my enemies. >> asked
this question. So So So Jen
How do you How do you delineate the good tigers from the super
predator tigers, dear Connor? How do you do that? >> I
know um is is known in our communities. Jen was >> snitching
on your community. She's like, you're talking crazy [__]
over there.
Do you think Connor isn't trying to end
No, I think Connor is trying to end Trump. Connor is to considering
supporting J.D. Vance. Considering supporting Ron DeSantis. That's
MAGA. Connor is not trying to end MAGA. He just doesn't like
Trump. No. Well, and also, yeah, you're right, because MAGA isn't
going away. We've already had this conversation again. >> Right.
So you're not trying to end MAGA. So Jen is wrong. So Jen is
wrong. So Jen is wrong. You're trying to You're You're You're
trying to take MAGA and make it a little bit more palatable and
be like J.D. Vance Cory Booker Jason. That's what you want. That's
what you and give you what you want. We All right. So I'll just
say it instead of asking Socratic. So I think that the reason
why populism is working in our current political environment
is because of wealth inequality, rapid demographic change, existential
technological shifts, and the dissolution of the social fabric.
I think those are the four things that are that are motivating
MAGA and motivating left-wing populists. And so as a result,
I don't think MAGA, the the movement that is motivated by these
four things, I don't think they're going away. I do want a more
competent technocratic political leader to address wealth inequality,
rapid demographic >> want you want MAGA. You just want
to be solution of the social fabric. You just want to create
an ideological framework to use MAGA. That's what you're doing.
That So do you. That's politics, baby. >> No, I WANT TO
DESTROY MY ENEMIES. That's what I want to do. No, you don't.
You want your enemies to become your friends. This is a democracy.
No, you're going to get a gun and you're going to go MAGA get
the [__] out of here. [__] violently,
you idiot. I want to destroy them in terms of power. >> them
to your political tribe. >> I No, I I I don't The The MAGA
ideology, I want to destroy that. I want it to discredit it.
I want it to be out of >> You're not going to. Matter of
fact, Zoran Momdani, you know what his favorite thing was that
he said during the Trump during the Trump press conference where
they mutually glazed each other for 45 minutes? He said, "Oh,
it was actually crazy, Mr. President. People walked up to me
on the streets of New York and they said that they voted for
Trump in the general, but they voted for Trump >> pandering.
That's called Hey, that's called pandering. economically populist.
Do you Do you watch Do you watch like advertise like, "Oh my
god, I didn't know that this was better than the leading brand."
It's called pandering. That's not MAGA ideology.
Dude. Dude, Connor.
>> That kind of is Connor is kind of like that, okay? That
is actually a fantastic dude.
>> That actually That actually is just like exactly true.
>> Connor's just got an opinion like forever until somebody
tells him otherwise. Like basically he hears something and he's
like, "Yep, that's the way that is." Forever. >> It's the
ideology Doesn't There's no like He doesn't have that thing where
he's like, "Wait." He's initially skeptical. Somebody just tells
him something, he's like, "That's the way that is." ideology
I want to end. I'm not trying to talk about like rounding up
people or anything. Okay, are you trying Okay, I'm trying to
end economic populism. You know why? I want the people to
Missy Elliott, if you keep talking about how Connor needs to
be saved from Groypers, I'm going to turn him into a Groyper
without actually being one myself. I'm just going to convince
him that the ideas are all good and he needs to be one, okay?
Let Connor make his own decisions. Don't Don't try to get Pisco
to mind control him. All right. I want to see where he goes on
his own. You got to let the butterfly go, okay? And see if it
comes back.
that they don't even want economic populism. I didn't think about
this. This is also That's what I want. I want to I want to design
a technocratic Connor Connor is literally too Aryan to be a Groyper,
okay? It's over. It's >> competent society to the point
that the working class and middle class don't want to rebel because
they actually like their lives. Yeah. I'm getting triggered.
I I want to lull the proletarian class to sleep. I don't I don't
want them to be revolutionary. I want the I want the proletarian
class to work 40 to 50 hours a week. I want their wife to not
work at all or work part-time. I want them to be able to afford
a reasonable standard of living and afford having children.
I don't know. Why did Pisco say no to that? What is Connor saying
here that's
Connor just said Connor literally used social like socialist
language to explain it. And I want their kids to go to good schools
and I want their kids to have decent economic opportunities.
>> want white people to be a plurality. And you And you
want And you want white people to be plurality.
the slumbering proletarian giant that Hasan [__]
and Zoran Momdani want to shake awake to the point that they
can overthrow the economic system. I want to I want to pet that
giant's back until he's lulled into beautiful
Uh I'm pretty sure even rank choice voting devolves into first
Not first past the post, but it does devolve into a two-party
system essentially, Packer
These things all basically turn into like two warring sides because
otherwise you essentially It's just like I don't know. There's
probably somebody's got a way better way of explaining it. Essentially
all electoral systems turn into like a like two opposing sides.
You have rare moments like especially high high pressure like
boiling point moments where approval voting Oh, replace first
past the post with approval voting. I have no idea what approval
voting is, so maybe. I don't even know what approval I I said
rank choice is usually the thing. I don't even know what approval
is. California government may may have two Republicans running
in the general.
Uh California governor? Yeah, possibly.
It doesn't mean that those those two sides are like Democrats
or Republicans. It just happens to be the most common breakup
in American politics.
I'm saying it usually comes down to two parties who are trying
to build coalitions to like oppose each other. >> full
sleep. So if if that's the case, what's wrong with Ro Khanna
going onto Hasan's stream to lull the populist tiger asleep?
Well, I have to actually watch the >> Oh, so there's nothing
inherently wrong with going on Hasan and doing a little belly
rub as long as you're trying to lull the populist tiger to sleep.
Isn't that what you're doing? >> Okay, but is he is he
smart enough to do that? Because most of you guys are not smart
enough to do that. You. This is all ad hoc. You're inventing
new things. When you realize that your entire framework for what
you're talking about is absolutely compatible with having amicable
podcast with lefties you don't like, you're like, "Oh, [__]
I have to come up with some other reason to distinguish my criticism
of Pisco and all these other people in the vanguard." >> No,
I think this is bull. What's bull [__] about it?
Not not I mean, that's that's also true. I think Connor's saying
totally reasonable things, but when he's saying these totally
reasonable things
that Hasan 100% believes, by the way. Well, sorry. Hasan is not
necessarily trying to lull them to sleep.
I I don't Man.
He says he's trying to lull thing lull people to sleep.
But man, do you think Fuentes is trying to lull them to sleep?
He's doing the opposite, right? The people lulling them to sleep
Do you When people feel their quality of life dropping, the person
lulling the them to sleep is like the enemy. That's the shill.
That's the shill you have to like They're the first one to go,
right? Not only No, this is total because I said in reference
to the vanguard thing, nobody gives a [__] that you're
talking to the vanguard. Nobody would give a [__]
if you went on to Hasan [__] The question Libs are
the one doing the sleeping spell, but I'm telling you that's
why liberalism is falling out of favor is because libs are the
one doing the sleeping spell. Now, there's a lot of people who
think that when that sleeping if that sleeping spell is broken,
they're going to The world's going to be better. Almost certainly
in the short term, the world's going to be significantly worse.
And almost certainly in the long term, the world's going to be
significantly worse.
God, I need to stop this. >> not you would actually differentiate
your positions to the point that you guys don't seem like you're
friends. Well, hang on a second. Wait a second. So the Hasan
We'll We'll talk about whether that's a criticism that that That's
the last. Does Hasan's base Do the people who watch him Do they
have genuine economic concerns and genuine like things that we
ought to appeal to? Okay. So then what is exactly is wrong if
it's okay for Momdani
to go to the And I think it's fine for him to go to the White
House as a envoy of New York City meeting with the purported
president of the United States and to have this little conversation
and to kind of signal and do the kind of virtue signal of, "Oh,
everyone cares about the same shit." type deal that every politician
does. What's wrong with that for lefties and for libs trying
to actually bring into the fold the more populous and disaffected
members of the >> Because that's like That's like being
in '39 Germany
and being like, "You know, there's this socialist critic of Adolf
Hitler and he went up to Berlin and then he was kind of, you
know, like, you know, he talked some crazy [__] about
him like a few times and he still said that he has those beliefs.
But realistically, he was cozying up to him in '39 because he
wants some territorial concessions. He want He wants
to let him keep a few Germans. He wants him to give him some
like redistributive economic policy so he can implement the socialist
agenda. And so that that's like the question. This is why a lot
of people get frustrated with the left is Is is Donald Trump
a megalomaniacal
incompetent degenerate
freak? I'm just going to say
if you can show me that as Nick Fuentes is on his rise
as Nick Fuentes is like popping the [__] off. If
you can show me Connor and a group around him, his community
like consistently trying to get the word out about this guy and
how he's like blowing up right now and how this is a huge problem.
Right? And how people need to stop debating or stop talking to
him, stop platforming him. If you could show me that then I would
believe he's sincere about the Hasan thing. Otherwise, I'd lean
in Pisco's direction and say you're not really sincere at all.
You just really hate Hasan. You really hate socialism. But you're
not sincere in like the the cat tiger analogy, right? You're
not sincere in that at all. You're literally just like you're
larping right now. You're pretending you care about this that
you think that's the same problem. Like one, I don't think it's
the same problem. Two, I don't think you actually really cared
to stop this problem the first time it happened or anything like
who is hundreds of thousands of people through incompetence and
who is fascistic in his political leanings or is he somebody
that you need to kiss the ring for in order to get concessions?
Yeah, I see like whenever you get the chance to frame it, sure.
Now you can make the historical analogy and Ro Khanna and me
and all these people, we're not trying to appeal to the disaffected
people with genuine concern. I think I think this is almost true.
I would change incompetent to just corrupt.
I think Trump is transparently corrupt. But if Trump were actually
doing all the things Trump said he would do and he wasn't just
lining his pockets and lining the pockets of every crony in his
whole administration, Connor probably wouldn't have a problem
with it. Connor probably be like, yeah, it's not so bad. Yeah,
it's not so bad. concerns that are you fueling these movements
Ooh, except he did seem to actually be concerned about the USA
ID. We are like the USA I don't know. The the the failing politicians
who are giving concessions. Okay, who's getting sock >> puppeted?
How on what basis are you to say Why why don't I say you're getting
sock puppeted by the the teal light Jarvanite class of techno
fascist? >> You're right. I'm being by a tiger right now,
Pisco. I I I I am being sock by a giant tiger and a Pisco. I
I I I am being sock by Oh, I can't go back fast enough with this.
[__] >> I I I I am being sock by a giant tiger
and I am saying Pisco.
I just need I might need that. Listen, if you could if somebody
could cut that for me
don't put the giant tiger in there, okay? I'll use it for an
alert or something. I'll figure out how to use it for something,
okay? Look out. That housecat might become a giant tiger and
start to you. And you're like, no, no, no, no, no, it's fine.
I'm being >> also totally fine. But you're also
>> by the tiger. But but you're but you're also scratching
the bottom of the tiger's chin who's currently griping >> It's
a different >> Hey, let me finish it. Wait, no, no. Pisco
lost. Pisco lost the whole
to the tiger's griping him.
Just say bro, you're on you dude. Just
Just say
The tiger is griping him.
>> You're you're scratching his chin saying, "Daddy, chill."
That's what you're doing.
>> Oh, what the [__] You're also >> tiger
and start to you. And you're like, no, no, no, no, no, it's fine.
>> But you're also totally fine. But you're also scratching
>> by the by the tiger. But but you're But you're also
scratching the bottom of the tiger's chin who's currently griping
>> It's a different >> Hey, let me finish it. Wait,
no, no. You're you're scratching his chin saying, "Daddy, chill."
That's what you're doing.
And meanwhile yes, yes. That's what you're doing.
No rebuttal. No rebuttal from Connor. >> Maybe the tiger
has some good ideas and some points. No, shut.
Dude, that is that is
Jesus Christ.
That's dire.
Oh my god. I got to say Connor going like maybe the thing he
has a valid point. That What is kind of on my bingo card for
Connor's opinion on something. Like I I feel like that's I feel
like I'm not shocked that that was what was said. Like I it is
funny, but I feel like that's sort of on brand a little bit.
>> Or I mean okay, prediction time. If I were to ever to
collab with Hasan, what would the reaction be? On any in any
Tiger said barb, right? Just to be
That's probably important to get on the record before we continue
the content. Tiger said barb, yes? At least one yes. Okay, I'm
going to assume that. >> Prediction time. If I were to
ever to collab with Hasan, what would the reaction be? On any
in any context? >> It depends on how hard you went. If
you guys were like best buddies and yucking it up and having
a good time, it would be you're you're a liberal >> how
I do it with you. More or less how I engage with you. SENTENCES
THAT YOU'RE PROBABLY asking for. You're a liberal traitor who's
sucking up to Hasan in order to steal some of his audience. You're
you're a clout demon who doesn't care how far left your audience
goes. Right, if I had the guy That would be that would be it
unless it was a contentious conversation. If it were a friendly
conversation like I'm having you. Like no, push back. Listen,
you should vote for Democrats. If it was a friendly conversation,
people would accuse you of being a clout demon trying to steal
the lefty audience because you don't care about the ideology
or the principles. You just care about growing your
And what you do? By the way, I heard this criticism when you
were going on
with Crystal Ball and Kyle Kulinski.
Yeah. So, I don't think I I think >> saying it's accurate.
I'm just describing what the criticism would be. I think that
what some people are proposing is a complete fortress arc for
liberals and not to talk to in friendly manners the people with
whom they disagree.
And I can understand that for certain types of people. I can
I have that thought with um with the MAGA people. I guess I just
see MAGA as worse than you do. I guess I think MAGA is worse
than what a lot of people think.
I dude, I I spend 70% of my time doing it about MAGA. What what
are we talking about here? No, I'm not saying you. I'm saying
other people. I I spend 70% of my time saying I'm currently being
socked by a tiger and I really wish he would get out of my butt
hole. Like >> but also daddy chill. Is that I don't know
if that's true. I Why did he say it again? But also daddy chill
and maybe I'll you know, maybe you're the next tiger in line.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Dude, I can tell where his mind was going.
Dude, Pisco, what are you doing? Pisco's really suddenly just
totally into this like tiger analogy. He's all the way in it.
>> daddy chill and maybe I'll you know, maybe you're the
next tiger [laughter] in line. I'm going to give the keys to
the castle. interesting part of the conversation. This is an
interesting part of the conversation.
So, I Turkeys, this went from a tiger analogy to a tiger gang
analogy. That's that's escalating fast. >> believe in Burkean
conservatism which basically means deferring to the status quo,
but it you know, and then criticizing and needling progressives
and liberals and implementing the good ideas and getting rid
of the bad ideas. That that's Burkean conservatism, okay? Now,
liberalism >> can you just repeat the last part of that?
So, Burkean conservatism is all that plus getting rid of bad
ideas and getting good ideas?
Yeah. Okay. Okay. So, the
uh as an example though, uh liberalism is oftentimes rooted in
maximal human freedom. We just disagree on where those lines
are. Here's a silly, but I think
mind exercise.
Let's say that you could generate I I'll just use sanitized terms
for the sake of the conversation. Let's say that you could generate
illicit
from AI
that did not technically hurt anyone.
What like my argument would be this is bad for your brain. It's
bad for neuroplasticity. Even if you don't harm any other people,
you're technically harming yourself. Any more than regular reasons
why we prohibit these Wait, any any more than regular
What's that? Any more than regular commercial consensual Wait,
yeah, is is illicit I'm I'm probably if I'm unclear, I'm talking
about chop. Oh, I thought you were talking about AI deep fakes.
Uh no. I'm talking about let's move How the [__]
does Counterpoints just turn any conversation to a a con How
do we get a you got to get another Pisco moment right here.
>> Just to be clear, I'm talking about child porn here.
Hold on. Why is he saluting? Uh no. I'm talking about let's move
it to the most extreme example just Oh, sweat. He's wiping the
sweater.
for the sake of
uh the example. So, with this most extreme example, technically
nobody's getting hurt except for the and we could change it to
drugs if that makes you more comfortable. Um technically nobody's
getting hurt except for the person who's involving themselves.
Uh if you are to impose a state limit on their behavior, you're
imposing on the you're imposing on them from the state. And arguably,
the harm from the state being
fines,
uh you know, social stigma, all that all that kind of stuff.
That's going to be, you know, super bad for the individual. So,
I guess my question to you is I can appeal to a conservative
reason for why this behavior should be prohibited. What is your
liberal rational? Do you believe that this behavior should be
prohibited? And then
if so, why from your liberal framework? So, I'm not sure that
I have a strong stance on the exact fact pattern that you're
talking about. Um I do think that there's You can go with hard
drugs if that makes it easier. >> No, no, no. But let me
let me contend with it. I'm not one to shy away from hypotheticals
in that context. I I think that there is definitely a liberal
framework to deal with these kinds of things because of course,
notwithstanding liberty, unless you're some kind of like libertarians,
the very ones that you want to put put in office, you all you
believe in ordered liberty and constitutional liberty. And that
of course conceptualizes
a notion of a harm to self. Um in fact, I think that um notwithstanding
the herd immunity um aspects to like vaccination things, I think
that there's an independent government interest in one's self.
Now, ultimately, I think that there's a big uh shown the government
and is need to uh needs to show for a huge infringement on a
protected core liberty. I do think that the per se banning of
is justified under a theory of production harm. And that production
harm relates to actual children being abused. And so, I do think
that the current framework
that banning doesn't apply to the AI stuff. However, there are
notions of obscenity. And I think at some level, I would agree
with certain levels of banning of obscenity. And that is certain
conduct that is so depraved, so out there uh to be commercialized
that the government has an interest um not just in terms of production
harm, but an interest in uh you know, in societal um you know,
individuals' mental health, that kind of stuff.
How are we talking about this? Connor brought up for some reason.
Basically saying like, how do liberals deal with this? >> actual
government ban though, I'm not sure that I would go that far.
Honestly, I've only tenuously been listening. I'm guessing it's
the AI generation of child, right? And why that's like that's
like a low rate of harm and how does a liberal framework handle
banning AI generated child porn or something? I have such a strong
value
free inquiry, free speech, and these kinds of rights. I'm concerned
not about the particular content that might be produced, but
about who decides the line. And I think that if if I could draw
a line, I want it to be based I'll be honest, I just want to
get out of the the child porn section.
>> So, there are things that By the way, I just disagree
with you here. So, so it it's not it's not a question of uh I
think you're a bad guy or I'm going to moral frog about
So, so it it's not it's not a question
uh I think you're a bad guy or I'm going
Agree with you here. So, so it it's not it's not a question of
I think you're a bad
guy.
I or I'm going to moral frog about it or whatever. I think that
disgust can be something that motivates our rationalizations
for why we engage in certain behaviors or prohibits No, no, that's
the start start. You didn't hear me. You You did not hear me.
So, I'm not saying that that doesn't occur. That of course disgust
will of course motivate one's behavior. The question
do I trust the government?
The government itself as a
I I'm not sure I listen.
I'm not always the biggest Counter-Points fan,
but I like him enough to not do that to him twice in a row. Okay,
I can't play it again. I'm sorry. >> concerned to do these
line drawings instead of things like production harm, instead
of things like um defamatory statements, instead of things like
um you know, the the proximity in terms of incitement, instead
of things like harassment when dealing with privacy or infliction
of intentional infliction of fear, just do it on disgust itself.
It's not a question of whether or not it rationally motivates
action. I agree with you that it does. The question is, do we
trust the government to draw lines of disgust? Because once we
allow subjective disgust to be something that the government
controls, well, I'm disgusted by communism. I'm disgusted by
fascism. I'm disgusted by a great many of ideologies that I can
directly tie to harm. That's what I'm concerned about. Not that
I think that this is good stuff or that it I think that it's
people something that people should consume. It's a question
of institutional competency. Is the government the right person
to enforce restrictions on speech that are ultimately just premised
on disgust by
Sure. You're like the last true liberal. But let's uh let let
me ask another question that I think and I'll tell you where
I'm going before we even go there that way we don't have to spend
time and people are like, where where's Connor going? He's talking
so much and saying nothing. Hey, [__] you, hater,
by the way, whoever says that. >> Connor's talking to me.
I'm the one who complains about that. Connor's talking to me.
>> that too, so we're good. Excellent. So, they should
be used to it. I usually understand where Pisco's going. The
uh what I was going to say is
You tag me with a Counter uh Connor sound bite. Oh.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on.
Oh, but is this going to get short enough? What Why don't I say
you're getting sock puppeted? Sorry, I was like the T light Yarvinite
class of techno-fascist being sock puppeted. By a tiger right
now, Pisco. I I I I'm being sock by a giant tiger.
Yeah. Thank you, though. It's good to know I I know I have a
clip to cut it out of now. Thank you. All right. Back to the
discussion. >> The The point of what I'm asking is that
I don't think liberalism is an excellent place to start, okay?
Uh liberalism emphasizes the sovereignty of the individual, it
emphasizes our conscious experience, it focuses on dignity, uh
it focuses on making sure that the powers that be don't abuse
the individual in the name of the public good, it sets reasonable
limitations on the actions of the government. Liberalism is an
excellent place to start.
However,
I do think that it's insufficient for a good human life, and
I think that morality
and like philosophy, religion, all these kinds of things that
and some of these are nested in political persuasions like social
conservatism. So, that's where I feel like liberalism is insufficient
and you have to turn to these other things. Liberalism is a style
of
liberalism is not um a philosophy that is pretending to be a
theory of everything with respect to morality. It's It is uh
a structure of a a framework for looking at rights and a framework
for looking about the relationship between the state and uh the
people. I mean, that's what it is. And it isn't anything more.
Yeah, yeah. So, but but I want to ask you something that might
be rooted a little bit more in a social conservative perspective.
So, with social conservatism, the uh the social promotion of
like what they would believe is pro-social uh behavior that's
rooted in religion. Um I Oh, what's up, Second? How's it going?
Welcome, welcome. I view religion as a I'm not a literalist,
okay? I'm not a literalist. Uh I'm a deist. I I believe in a
creative force that set things in order, but I don't really believe
in an afterlife. I don't think Jesus is the Messiah. I think
effectively it's a mythology. But I think that this mythology
is important, and I see arslers in my chat constantly arguing
that we can totally ignore uh religion as a vehicle for morality,
and yet they're total totally lost degenerates themselves. And
so, I guess my question is like, what what is your perception
of religion? Are you completely hostile to it? Do you view it
as a necessary evil? Do you view it as a vehicle for morality?
What what what's your perception of it? I take a Marxian view
on religion. Um religion is the sigh of the oppressed, the sigh
of the oppressed creature. It is an opiate of the masses.
Uh listen, I ultimately view religion and mythologies and myth-making
as human beings' attempt to explain that which they cannot explain
and to produce meaning where there is fear and uncertainty. I
think that um fear is almost defined by uncertainty. Uncertainty,
in other words, is fear. Why are you like uh afraid of the dark?
Because you don't know what's behind it, right? Like Like fear
and uncertainty are go one in one. And I think religion is um
is a term that is meant to capture uh humans' various different
attempts to explain phenomena, explain value, explain meaning.
And as such, uh I I don't think it's it's really helpful to say
something If Pisco ever bristles at getting called being called
gay, I need this clip. I need to remember this clip so I can
say that like, hey, uncertainty and fear are the same thing.
When you when you're acting homophobic right now, okay? Uncertainty
and fear are the same thing. >> like religion is bad or
religion is good generally unless you're being a little bit more
specific about what you mean. If what you mean by religion is
bad or something is just like closed systems of thought are bad,
maybe I could say that's that's kind of like um you know, it's
my preference. It's my preference. I I think that those kinds
of closed systems of thought that most religions inhabit Okay,
what else what else is going on here? Cuz I I loaded this up.
I just realized I'm like actually
I I don't know why. I feel like I can probably like have a nap
and come back and stream more. We're almost at 7 hours. Is there
more stuff here? Do we have to skip past some [__]
Cuz it looks like they talk for a while longer. Does this get
back to the the groper [__] at some point?
Did they get off of
the garbage
s- and and then it goes into religion?
Talk about the limits of liberalism. Do they get off of this?
not good. Um I I don't I don't think that they're not good. There
are aspects about certain religious philosophies, certain religious
communities that are very Not that Not that these conversations
are bad. I just like I don't You have to be in the right mood
for one of these conversations. I'm almost never in the mood
for one of these
Like you you have to be like high or something to want to have
this
>> I think the one thing that secular communities often,
though it's not necessarily that they have this, but they do
lack, is a sense of community. Uh that's not all I want to say
that. But sometimes I feel that there is a shared sense of ritual,
a shared sense of togetherness, of peoplehood that is lost absent
some of these traditions and rituals. But I think that that is
uniquely religious stuff. I think that very innate form of human
societal almost kind of grooming and agreement within a tribe.
So, my answer to that is, it depends. I think that religion has
been a positive force in the world over the course of years.
It's been a positive force in good and ultimately our lives.
Yeah, so so I have a a more positive view of religion where uh
once again, not a literalist. But I was raised in the church.
I went to church every Sunday. Like as a saying.
Israel and Judea. And so, the argument is that only I mean, but
then my question for you is the one the teachers always ask,
so what? So, what do we do with that? And you should I agree
so. No, I agree so. But like, why does that But also I think
it
Well, it's in So, our societies even now, the politicians are
mostly religious. People in charge are mostly religious. We still
have a prayer at So, why is that liberalism false? That's just
that's just correlation. If I look at the stats on secularization
and church attendance, effectively it's gone from like in the
past two or three
The attendance with church attendance was at like weekly. So,
why is that liberalism false? That's just that's just correlation.
That's just Sure. And and by the way, I'm not arguing that everybody
needs to return to church. I don't go to church weekly. The The
The point is though that like
I would say liberalism
as as liberalism became more of the way of thinking, it became
more of like ingrained in people's like general thought process,
the idea of like organize I man, I don't know if you get tied
to religion. There's like the idea of collectivism is is sort
of like shunned in some ways. The idea of that shared that shared
ritual is something to be
But I I don't think there's got to be a bigger source. It can't
just be like smug liberals mocking religion is the reason it
like failed. Man, I'm trying to think.
There's ties to a lot of different things here. I don't have
like a I don't have like an automatic like everything
to explain this. I feel like it's mostly to do with um
I think religion stayed fairly strong until we started getting
like video games and stuff. Until it started becoming like really
awesome to just not go to church. You just had really awesome
[__] to do. That's basically how I feel about it.
I got awesome [__] to do. I got a [__]
Xbox. Halo just came out. Why the [__] would I go
to church? I feel like that's sort of where things went. No,
the enlightenment was way before this. I'm saying why religion
didn't fall off in America until considerably later. Religion
isn't necessary anymore. I think that's just wrong. Um I at least
like I think religion hasn't been replaced. I think
I think there's a reason religious people are happier by and
large,
to be honest. Like
Pisco just got owned.
>> Um I think almost the the prohibition on is probably
correlated with disease. You need to prove that. No, I don't.
Uh the Abrahamic prohibition against
was likely a correlation with disease. Same thing with like shellfish
and pig. You need to prove that.
No, I don't. So, be because You can just say it. You can just
say it. You what what do you I don't even want to get into this
because like
Just say granted that yeah.
Then no, I don't. Pisco's naturally going to bristle at that
because he gets really [__] annoyed when people
But Connor's just saying like take it as given. Take it as given
for now.
And have the conversation. Why do you think shellfish were prohibited
in the ancient world? Because Frank ate a shellfish and he had
an allergic reaction and he died. Why was pork in the ancient
world?
I would actually think shellfish is probably for being improperly
cooked is also something that carries disease.
I don't think it's allergic reactions in the ancient world, probably.
You're just saying it. Why why did they take people's why why
did they circumcise people take people's foreskins off? Because
Abraham had a Abraham had a
Well, no. So so it's it's your false contention or I don't know
assumption that religious beliefs
Is Connor guy snarking right now? What the [__] is
wrong? What the [__] is wrong with this guy? Premised
on some kind of underlying rational set of
inferences and practices.
But but what justifies that? No, but what but that's that is
a pure aesthetics. That would belie your notion that there's
some like underlying health Phimosis is a real medical condition
that can be painful.
When when your when your head when the hood of your foreskin
fuses to your tip and then your continues Yeah, and circumcision
can also
it's painful. Yeah, circumcision especially a medical condition
that occurs in like two
Bro, what is Connor [__] on right
What are you Dude, what is he
And circumcision cannot cause be the cause of infection and disease
and stuff, especially back in the day with older instruments?
No, it can be, but a properly done circumcision
can prevent
Okay, and what about Okay, but What is Is it really your contention
that the religious practices from the Bible
Hey, why why they got to bite the dick
You tell me that what medical condition does it help when you
bite the dick?
Tell me why they bite the dick, Connor.
Just tell me explain why they bite the dick, Connor. That's all
you got to do.
Are based in some rational or logical set of choices that that
support human flourishing in some kind.
They're not purely rational, but I do think that they often times
are rooted in a level of like observation of like moral action
and their consequences, of
All right, I don't know what justifies that inference. You're
just assuming it. Fair? No, oh no No, it's actually perfectly
rational. So, sorry. Uh Muhammad, peace be upon him, okay? When
he came into uh the pagan Arabian world that was a part of the
Eastern
uh Eastern Roman Empire, which was largely Christian, in his
pagan sect of the world, infanticide uh female infanticide was
still practiced.
And so, if people had children and they were women because because
of inheritance laws, they would take the infants, they would
put them inside clay pots, they would walk them out in the desert,
and they would kill them. Yeah, this was the practice This was
the practice of pre-Islamic Arabia.
Hold on, there's an evolutionary psychological reason why people
would do that, but there's also a reason why because Muhammad,
peace be upon him, would sympathize and empathize with the women
who are being killed and therefore come up with a social prohibition
against that practice as a part of his religion. It was a moral
analysis of real facts.
So, like like how how are you disconnecting How are you saying
every religious prescription is completely
No, I'm not saying that they're all irrational or they're Prove
every religious prescription is irrational. No, I'm not saying
that. I'm saying in any given instance, I think it's the burden
of proof on the person promoting it to suggest that the the origin
of it comes from some ultimately, you know, humanistic improperly
cooked pork. Follow me down this logic train because this is
actually frustrating to grant the health stuff. I'm I'm going
to grant all the health stuff. Because we were talking about
and we were talking about Chesterton's fence, right? Yeah. That
that was the original thing. Okay, so let's get back to that
real quick. So,
sanitary practices in the ancient world are probably not what
they are today, okay? And in the past 200 years, we have invented
condoms,
douches,
uh indoor plumbing, although arguably that was around at the
time, but obviously we've enhanced it a lot in the past two centuries.
We we we have all these enhancements that have
allowed us to get over the sanitary practices that were or excuse
me, the lack of sanitary practices
potentially deadly in the ancient world, okay? So, what we can
do from a
Uh okay.
Yeah, you do have to go back Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait.
What did they do in like Greece that
so much like more accepted? What was going on in Greece that
they were just like, "Yeah, whatever." [__] that
dude in the ass. Wouldn't they wouldn't the health concerns have
applied there? in the ancient world, okay? So, what we can do
from a Chesterton's fence analysis is we can say
was prohibited not because it was like a intelligent understanding
of human nature and the divine creator of the world gave us this
prohibition because gay people are gross. We can say this was
likely an evolutionary psychological argument that we have surpassed
through technology. This is heresy.
This is heresy.
This is This is heresy. This is revisionism. This is heresy.
Correct. I'm not a religious literalist. Okay, but but all you're
doing, right? All you're doing is be and you think you're smarter
than everybody, is you are editing what they take to be the inherent
word of God.
Breaks a lot of heresy. Yeah, but I'm saying he's arguing that
there's a health reason behind it. And I don't know that there's
a health reason behind it. I wants to divert Nick's audience
isn't even Christian. Wait, he's not Christian, but I don't know
if he wants to divert. Oh.
He's not cool enough to do it. That's the problem.
That's the unfortunate thing. Oh, didn't Connor or sorry, didn't
Nick like totally [__] on Warhammer recently? Hold
Can I can I find this? I'm trying to Did he I feel like he Am
I hallucinating this? I thought this just happened. Oh, it did
just happen, too.
fascism, Halo, Helldivers, Warhammer
Oh god. Oh god. Yo, you [__] You [__]
with space fascism, dog?
with space fascism, Halo, Helldivers, Warhammer 40K, StarCraft.
If you like Call of Duty and real-time strategy, you should try
Warhammer 40K. You definitely be in the Black Templars. Yeah,
you're you're just like a disgusting nerd. I hope you know that.
You're a disgusting nerd. You [__] with space fascism?
Like go back to Reddit and then commit su there.
Okay, Reddit is down the hall to the left. Please kill yourself
when you get there. Thank you.
You would love Warhammer. You'd definitely be Black Templar.
Dude, can we get Connor to Can we get Connor to watch this clip
and then update his scoreboard for who he'd vote for for president?
Can we get him to watch this clip and then he gave $50 to Nick
Fuentes and Nick did him dirty like this. This is crazy. Okay,
don't you have like a Magic: The Gathering game to get to? Reddit
is over there. Thank you very much.
>> That's just I'm sorry. We cannot permit I can't even
indulge that a little bit because if I do, then we're going to
get all these smelling disgusting weirdos. You like Helldivers
and Warhammer and
Dude, I got to turn I got to turn um what do you call followers
only chat on for I got to turn the timer back on. So many people
just have I don't know if it's bots. That could have been a real
guy who just came in and was like, "You want to check out my
thing?" It's like, "I'm sorry."
Don't come into my chat and advertise your sh- If you're a real
person, okay? Go to the Discord, use the promotion channel, at
me or something. Indulge that a little bit because if I do, then
we're going get all these smelling disgusting weirdos. You like
Helldivers and Warhammer and Halo?
I dress up as Master Chief for Halloween, and I'm 38.
Sorry, pal. We're just not down with that.
Oh god. Dude, hold on. Can I Can I set this up? I
Oh, I'm so far away from being able to set this up. Just a second.
I'm seeing the vision, okay? I'm seeing the vision. Oh, wait.
Where's Oh, hold on. I need the picture.
I need a picture. I need a picture. I need a picture.
God, Connor tweets way too much.
I need a picture of Connor with his
Connor with his bolter. Connor with his
Holy [__] Hold on. It's a guilty pleasure. Treat
it disgusting weirdos. You like Helldivers and Warhammer and
Halo?
I dress up as Master Chief for Halloween, and I'm 38.
Sorry, pal. We're just not down with that. It's a guilty pleasure.
Treat it with like It's okay to have guilty pleasures. You just
can't talk about them and you have to have them outside. It's
okay. Just never talk about it. He's right there. He's right
there.
I was going to do a whole bit with music. I'm I'm a little past
it. I'm I'm God or at least divinely inspired word of God. That's
what it is, man. And so like
You're saying What is chat's estimate of Noor's IQ? I'm leaning
towards 100.
Wait, who? Noor? Connor. Connor's IQ. I know what these people
meant.
Connor's not like as Connor's like
There's something going on. I know what the people who Okay,
but that is in That would be anathema to any religious person
who is serious about their
Yeah, it would be anathema to any literalist.
Any Anybody who thinks that the planet is 6,000 years old, anybody
who thinks that Jesus Christ or Muhammad or Moses or whatever,
they literally heard the voice of the creator of the universe,
that you're right. This would
uh against their beliefs. So if you feel confident to to edit
the Bible with a scalpel, I'm just going to do the same
Wait, why? If you don't believe in divine command, why wouldn't
you just be a liberal? Literally, the only thing you get out
of that is like the whole point of religion is that that's just
how it is. Like that's literally just how it is, and you follow
it because that's like a supreme entity came down and said, "This
is how it is."
If you don't believe it literally,
you're not going to follow it literally. If you don't believe
in the literal stories, why even be religious? It doesn't make
any sense. He treats Christianity the same way he treats
Yeah, maybe. But then like you don't even need You don't need
Christianity. Why not use the thing that's distilled out into
modern society?
You literally don't need Christianity at
If you don't believe in any of the stories literally. If you
don't believe that God was really speaking to the people in that
book, I have no f- idea
why Sorry, why in the world
you say you're Christian or even like a deist or whatever the
[__] he says. What is it? It's something deism.
Uh he's got a stupid name for it. Yeah, but yours is worse than
mine. Okay, so it all get gets ground down into a moral argument.
So what do we need the religion for? Correct. Not because because
reli- because Yeah, that that's sorry. Maybe Was I just Was I
just like not really paying attention to Episcopal but absorbing
the conversation? perspective, which effectively says there's
a reason why we created these fences and created these rules.
Okay. All right. So let's the hubris. Hold on. The hubris of
modern
Then why Then literally But then you run into things like
So is it just the the Is it the fences you don't understand why
they're there that are the most important? You're like, "Well,
I don't understand why they're there, but they must be important
cuz we made them a long time ago."
If not, then the religion the religion is harmful. people is
believing Somebody said it. There There are no fences. There
are no rules. We can create all of the We can But in any given
instance but in any given instance
Basically, [clears throat] are you talking about burdens here?
So burdens. Who has the burden to show to bring down the fence?
Is that what you're trying to Yeah, I'm I'm saying that yeah,
it's it's incumbent upon progressives and liberals who want to
bring down a fence to argue why it will not cause a disaster.
All right. So Fine. I could even say that um I agree with that
that we're you're Oh, so it is basically if you can't explain
why why a fence is there
or why taking it down isn't hurtful or harmful, sorry, then leave
it there. building from a structure, not for the religious kind
of ex- I don't know what Chesterton's fence is.
Chesterton's fence. Oh, is this the idea that like the fence
is keeping a wolf out, right? That like Yeah, okay. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Never mind. I do know what Chesterton's
tribulations that you've had, but this notion of something that
has undergirded our society. If we're going to But then But then
obviously, if you believe it in that,
but you don't you aren't like literal. I'm trying to think of
like what rule in the Bible you wouldn't know why it was
or you wouldn't understand like why it was made,
but you would follow it anyway.
I'm trying to think of like which one it would be. To change
something in a radical way, there should be reasons for it, and
the people who want to get rid of it should should produce those
reasons. That's fine as an assumption. I'm not against that assumption.
I think it's weird how you're tying it into the doctrine itself,
but fine. If you want to go that way, you can go ahead. I don't
understand what it has to do with liberalism because liberalism
doesn't make prescriptions of those kinds. It's not liberals
who have uh from the perspective of liberalism, the framework,
the structure. There perhaps people who are consider themselves
liberals who have you know, attacked No. No. No. I understand
the concept. I understand the concept. I'm saying why do you
need the religion? If you The religion is there to say the reason,
even if you don't understand it, the reason you leave it up is
because you have the religion. If you're just going to say, "I
believe that we leave those things up because we can't define
why they're like good or bad because we don't know why they're
there." Then it's like, "Okay, well then you just don't need
the religion at all." religion and what have you, but the structure
of liberalism is totally compatible with religious ideology,
with religious thought. And so in what sense um are you attacking
liberalism for the fault of lack of religiosity or what have
what have you? Given two things. Given the fact that religious
thought is compatible with it, and there's nothing In fact, it
would be incompatible with liberalism to the gov- for the government
actively to go against religion. That It would be In other words,
freedom of religion is one of the liberties entailed by liberalism.
And so Fact number one is religious acceptance is not or at least
we we should not allow our government to affect those things,
and liberalism supports the freedom of religion. And And then
number two, um the fact that like uh lack of religiosity is occurring
in Western society, that you're just trying to track a correlation
causation. You haven't even done the building blocks of establishing
a link there. So tell me what those I think they're pretty good
gaps. Yeah. So I don't know if it's a good answer.
What do you not get? It's paternalism. Jordan Peterson and Connor
think they're society's parents, and that if critical mass doesn't
believe it, everyone will pay a price.
Um No, I understand that, but then like basically, you're admitting
that >> you don't believe in the like core foundation of
why these things are
And so you're just grifting. You're literally By saying that
these things are important cuz they're old, but also trying to
perform the religion, you're just grifting the people in that
religion openly. But in a way where you're telling them you're
grifting, right? Like you are literally saying, "I am grifting.
I am trying to use your religion to manipulate you, but I don't
really believe in it." I want you
I I don't believe in God. I don't believe that God told all these
people in the Bible what was Jesus Christ. Holy sh- Hold on.
Oh, one second. I have to go figure out what the [__]
just fell in my house. Holy [__]
Something so loud just banged like in my house. If I I miss you
guys. I'll miss you guys, okay?
If somebody's here, they they really did find me.
Oh boy, hold on. It is my perspective that the conservatives
in regardless of how you frame it are the people who are staring
at all of these proverbial metaphorical fences, and they're saying,
"We should keep these fences." Now, some of those fences no longer
make sense.
talking about because you got to talk about them over. You understand
that like libertarian and liberals and non-religious conservatives
are okay with tearing down the trans fence exclusively for adults,
the contention the cultural backlash of the last decade has been
specifically about trans
what is the fence that liberals are trying to tear down from
the structure from the structure of liberalism
Well, I mean we could actually just go down like a a list of
them. And by the way, it might not even be liberals who are ne-
I have no idea what it was.
I can't find whatever the [__] fell over in my house
that made this massive bang.
And now I'm getting really [__] concerned. Little
concerned that it was my neighbors like banging on a wall or
something being like, "Shut the [__] up."
They've never done that before even though I scream super late
and scream all the time. necessarily doing it. It could in fact
be progressives, and I do differentiate
liberals, progressives, and leftists separately, but because
of our political binary, liberals are often I'm like s- I'm super
freaked out. Something just banged like so loud in my apartment
and I cannot find something that fell over.
times in a political coalition with progressives and leftists,
right? So, when it comes >> to liberal So, then we just
need to clarify terms. When you talk about liberals, are you
talking about the political left in America or you talking about
liberalism like a doctrine of a structure of ordered liberty
and government I think for the sake of this conversation, we
should probably say the left wing of America. Okay. Uh because
otherwise it's going to get too messy. >> All right. So,
then I'm I'm with you.
Okay. So, the left wing of America
Uh I only have one door and it's locked. It was locked, so I'm
fine on that front. Oh, maybe it was something in my basement
fell over. Was I down there recently? Was.
Maybe it was something in my basement fell over. Oh, I didn't
look at my closet, either. I don't know. Could have been something.
Check under your bed. >> When it comes to uh gay rights,
which I agree with, uh but trans rights, which we need to be
nuanced about, uh illicit drug consumption and immigration,
those are the fences that we're fighting over right now as a
society. Okay, so this is stupid because when you talk about
>> There's nothing wrong WITH WHAT I JUST SAID. YES. SO,
[laughter] you're you're pretending
that immigration is this old as [__] dirt uh fence
that liberals are trying to tear down and by which you mean the
political left. And there's two huge >> it's happened since
'65. There are There are two humongous prob- Oh my god. You're
actually believing Fuentes on Immigration Nationality Act and
Hart-Celler. This is how far your Fuentes has gone. It's descriptive.
You just Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. >> it's happened since
'65. There are two humongous prob- Oh my god. You're actually
believing Fuentes on Immigration Nationality Act and Hart-Celler.
This is how far your Fuentes has gone. You just You just cited
the Fuentes You just cited You just cited the Fuentes talking
point of the Hart-Celler Act. You just did it. When he totally
lies about that. If you look AT DEMOGRAPHICS IT'S
YOU'RE A GROPER. YOU'RE A GROPER. UH THIS IS PASCO'S genuinely
sawing out. This is just This is very silly. I think he's joking.
I think he's joking.
He's very lazy. >> immigrate to this country. YOU'RE A
[__] GROPER.
I'M NOT EVEN SAYING good or bad.
I'm not even saying No, you heard this from Fuentes. I know it.
I KNOW THE [__] I LISTEN to Fuentes, >> IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHERE I HEARD IT FROM IF IT'S DESCRIPTIVELY TRUE
WITHOUT I'M NOT making a moral claim about it. You're the one
jumping TO A MORAL PERSPECTIVE ON IT. SO, HERE'S here's the problem.
So, so problem number one is for most of human society open borders.
Open borders.
So, immediate non sequitur. How is that relevant to anybody's
point?
What is that relevant to? >> including in America. The
first restrictive immigration law in America, the Page Act, 1875.
For most of our from the framers to that point, no restrictive
immigration laws in America. People just come a
Okay, but isn't that like entirely
traveling significant distances at that point was
Like like really really really really really really really really
really really really really really really really really really
hard?
across. So, you're trying to cite this
>> NOBODY HAS HAD THE TECHNOLOGY TO COME >> SO, then
Okay. Okay. Wait wait wait wait. If that's the case, then don't
say this is a a rule as old as time. Don't say that then. It
doesn't get all of this as Hold on. No, it isn't. Do I need to
pull up wolf migration patterns for you? Like dude What does
that matter? Wolves don't don't have Do I need to pull up the
history of every empire on Earth? Like what the [__]
are we talking about here? You're You're saying that people haven't
collectivized
>> go places.
based off of ethno-religious
>> That's different. That is different. That's true within
borders. >> How is that different? I'd say for individuals
open borders,
right? Yeah, sure. Like you could basically go across a border.
Although,
like the ability to travel
Like I'm trying to think of like Rome cuz that's normally what
I could think of. Like for a German to go over to Rome and be
like, I just want to go see Rome. Like they might let an individual
German
But like there's no education in Germany at that point.
All the Germanic tribes are like like barbarians, actual barbarians.
How do they even go to Rome Like it's just like it's a it doesn't
happen because it's like wildly impractical to do so. And that's
it's so much so that when you had a person from like a foreign
place at some big like historical thing happening in those societies,
when you had somebody who from like far away, they're like notable.
We hear of a black guy in from like the sub-Saharan part of Africa
in Rome, everybody would know who that guy is.
Right? Like everybody if he was popular, if he was like somebody
known, if he was like traveling with any nobility, if any aristocracy,
they'd know who Everybody would know who that guy is.
Right? Like you'd be incredibly notable. I don't know. It's like
a very different
You just don't get You don't get like any kind of serious migration
until
I mean, I guess you start getting roads. >> That's true
within Actually, hold on.
Like sorry, I am basically saying that everyone around the Mediterranean
is the same, though.
America. That's true any That's true of human society.
No no no no Evil Johnny Bravo, I'm talking about individuals
moving. Um it wouldn't just be the Huns. It would be all the
Germanic tribes. It would be the Gauls. Lots of barbarian tribes
came down with like raiding parties and tried to with Rome. Absolutely.
But like those would be groups of people. It's not open borders
to like a massive roving horde.
Wait, what did you say?
When the Huns Not the Huns? I Anyway, it's it's fine. But like
individuals probably could have gone, but it's just wildly impractical
for individuals to travel that way. That's true of of of creatures.
You get like traders. Traders were allowed to move back and forth.
You are conflating the the tribal associative
sort of natural biology sense of migratory patterns with the
immigration problem. Different things, Connor. Different things.
That's the Why are they different? Literally Literally the argument
and by the way, I still haven't even staked out my position on
this at all. I've been descriptive, but you're attacking it as
if I want to >> no you know you know You are making a How
is the argument exclusively from immigration hawks
not
We have a certain like we have a multitude of ethnicities, obviously,
but we also have a religious
dot like one religion that dominates the demographics of the
United States of America. And if we allow mass unfettered immigration
from Central and South America, which I find silly,
but also from the Middle East and North
we will be changing the ethno-religious
of the United States of America and therefore changing
I'm way better at I feel like I'm way better at like talking
about this stuff.
I don't I cuz I don't think it's bad. I'm I'm like down for the
experiment. You want to try not having like a white majority
in this country? Yeah, I'm down for that. I I don't know if it's
going to go well. Everybody else is like there's no reason it
can't go well and I'm like, well, I don't think it's going to
go well, but or I don't know that it's going to go well. I'd
say I probably lean towards it going well. But it's like it's
a high enough risk that I'm just like, I don't know. >> our
destiny into the future in perpetuity. That means actually their
argument, regardless of whether or not you assign it a certain
moral weight. I'm not addressing that argument yet. I will. I'm
addressing its historical pedigree or the historical pedigree
that you are trying to assign to immigration itself. Now, YOU
DID A VERY WEASEL THING. I'M TRYING TO DESCRIBE IT AND you're
saying it's wrong before we even get past the description. Your
description of it having a historical pedigree is wrong. That's
what's wrong. You You've made this structure
Why is Why is Pasco saying that when America came along and they're
like, actually we're not going to you know, discriminate against
certain countries in terms of immigration anymore. Like basically
you don't have like quotas from certain places.
Wouldn't that Wouldn't that fundamentally
shift the way immigration would work?
Or were they just not Was it basically like, oh, we had unfettered,
you know, African migration and Mexican migration to the states
in 1965. I'm just trying to think of like why Why What would
his argument be for that not I'm just looking at what the Hart-Celler
Act is and I'm like, well, it sounds like this would have the
effect of changing how This sounds like it would have the effect
of changing the demographic makeup of the country.
I I actually don't know why he's against
Like what is his argument against this? Is it that like, well,
we didn't have
Cuz obviously if that thing it still existed, if you could still
discriminate or put quotas on certain countries,
wouldn't that have been possibly used or couldn't that have been
possibly used to fight certain immigration waves? I Like I I
actually don't understand why he's >> Sure. Which I've
tentatively think makes sense, which is don't tear down fence
or don't like remove things that you don't know what they are
or what their benefits are. Think about it before you do. That's
something that makes sense. And one of those examples is, well,
liberals, by which you mean the political left in America, are
trying to tear down the fence of of immigration. And that that
is uh ascribing to it the kind of historical pedigree that you're
giving to the times of Abraham. That's the kind of what the kinds
of examples you were
Oh, I think No, I
Oh,
I could
If Connor wrote this out, he could describe it better, too. I
think what the argument is here is Connor's saying that there
is this fence that exists. It's that, you know, people usually
congregate. There's usually a majority opinion, and if you're
outside of that majority, you know, to like kind of respect that
majority. That is the historical norm everywhere forever, right?
If you are in a country that's like a different ethno-religious
group, different makeup, different cultural makeup, you sort
of respect their customs. When in Rome, when in Rome, right?
When in Rome is a is a very old saying, all right? You you do
these things. You follow the customs. You you don't question
things, right?
And Pesco's saying, "Well, you can't say that that's like a part
of the Bible." I think Connor's saying there's a fence
and that Hartseller
got rid of that fence.
And I don't think that's like particularly
And And Pesco's saying, "Well, they didn't have policy that prevented
like immigration from other places." It's like, "No, they had
no way to actually immigrate en masse into new areas." And literally,
if you had enough people coming over, they would call that an
invasion, and they'd go kill the people who came in. Like, if
you just had a group of Gauls, like 5,000 Gauls roll into Rome,
they'd go, "Oh, that's a [__] That's a [__]
barbarian horde. Yeah, kill them all." So, I I feel like Connor
is not even I actually I feel like Pesco's sowing here pretty
hard. Using We're Abrahamic
Well, if Connor's saying religion's the reason or religion is
the reason for it, I'd say there's a fence there that exists
that is old that he could defend like not wanting to tear down
cuz he's a working conservative or something. I don't know what
part of it is defined in the Bible. It's not codified in the
I wouldn't try to use religion to justify it.
Especially somebody who doesn't actually literally believe the
religion.
Benjamin Franklin was one of the founders of this nation. He
was big about mass German immigration as soon as the founding
of the nation had
Swardoids coming into my country. God, Benjamin Franklin was
awesome. I need to read more about Benjamin Franklin. All these
conversation No, no, no. There was all these conversations about
Native American integration. There was all these conversations
about Mexican integration into the United States. There was all
these conversation There was like the Chinese Exclusion Act,
which we would need to look up for. So, pretend like Actually,
the founding fathers were agnostic on the ethno-religious makeup
of the people coming to the United States of America. The only
person who that is true can say that.
It sounds to me it sounds like Pesco thinks Connor's using the
religion to justify not wanting immigration change or justify
wanting like an uh ethnic majority, ethnic or religious majority
in the country. I'm not sure he was doing that. So, so hang hang
on. Everybody else had a [__] opinion. So, so this
is the problem. This is why people call me a pedant is because
I cuz people will sneak into the conversation concepts that aren't
heard when they say the word. So, when you say liberals are trying
to tear down immigration as And it's a fence that has a historical
pedigree pedigree going down back to the days of Abraham. Yeah,
oh, he is doing that. I didn't I didn't feel like Connor was
saying that. I didn't feel like Connor was saying that. Um I
I wish Pesco other uh time immemorial type style idea. What everyone
hears is immigration from the point of view of nations, immigration
from the point of view of restrictive immigration laws. That's
what everybody hears. Now, what you just said and what I wouldn't
uncover if I wasn't specific with my language is something different,
which is concerns regarding
religious ethnic groups and being part of an ethnic heritage
and uh race of people who is at least powerful. Yes, that concern
tracks or hysterias, I might say, tracks back thousands of years,
but it's not what you said. What you said was immigration.
It was immigration. I need the one with the finger in focus.
I thought the finger was in focus for a
There we go. That's the one.
Somebody put in big white letters, "You are chud." Okay? And
we have our Pesco Fuentes meme, okay? We're going to start spamming
this under Avi's replies everywhere on Twitter. >> Don't
do that. Don't That's just a total joke. I do not want anyone
to do that ever. That's a total joke. Please do not do that.
It's a It's completely I disavow my own joke, my own comment,
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. literally the the
I just googled like when was the first American immigration law?
This is >> so funny, though. I'm sorry.
>> up. What I said shut the shut the up. I did not say
the first immigration law. What were the words I chose? I don't
even know. It's
Listen, cuz you don't
Shut the [__] No, no, you just made a claim. This
is why because people will people will just lie.
Counter, you just lied. I didn't say or you didn't listen, and
I don't know which is worse. No, I said the first restrictive
immigration law, by which I mean the border control. So, look
up the Page Act right now. Go to Wikipedia. No, the 1799
Act
You're talking about You're talking about the Alien and Sedition
Act.
I'll be a pedant. So, 1799 Immigration Act specifies that free
white persons are the only people who can be naturalized in the
United States. person comes to the United States, can they become
a part of our nation, Pesco?
Connor, is that a natural Connor, it Connor Would it restrict
So, they could Yes, they could come. They could come. They They
could Connor, Connor, Connor, >> Connor, they couldn't
become a US citizen. What What did you just say there? Look at
that sleight of hand.
Sneaky [__] from you. Sneaky as Sneaky as Connor,
Connor. No, I'm not doing this anymore. I'm I'm not Connor, I'm
not I'm Connor, Connor, Connor, I'm not being nice anymore. That's
a naturalization law, isn't it? Yeah. It's not an immigration
law, is
I mean, I'll take I'll take it Is it an immigration law or not?
IS IT WHAT IS
IS IS WHAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED immigration or naturalization?
Which is Let me take a look. No, no, what Just answer the question.
Look at me and answer the question. I have to Google it. No,
you know what it is. It's not immigration to change status to
become a citizen. That's naturalization.
When you immigrate somewhere, you physically move to it to live
there permanently. You know that's what immigration is. You don't
need to look that up. Are you A STUPID PERSON?
GOD, I I think I think
I like the direction.
I like the
I think I have this problem where if I'm trying to like talk
somebody, it's usually cuz I'm like actually angry at
I think it works way better if you can maintain a layer of calm,
disconnectedness,
and
just slowly like talk them. You don't have to hide like your
annoyance or your
but I do think that like getting like getting like actually angry,
that's uh I don't know. But But I Listen, you can run your channel
whatever way you want. I think the anger is like um
It seems a bit much. I think Connor doesn't mind it, though.
Connor likes getting in angry conversations. Connor really does.
So, he might not have so so much of a problem with it.
And if, you know, if two consenting adults want to get together
and
you know, get chippy with each other, get chippy in the privacy
of their own Discord call, like
who am I to get in the way of that? When you immigrate somewhere,
you physically move to it to live there permanently. You know
that's what
What the [__] did you just send me? Can I play THIS
ON STREAM?
NO. NO, DO NOT DO I'M going to open it for the sake of a laugh
so everybody can laugh, but we're never ever using it. It's just
a joke. It's just a joke. It's just a joke. It's just a joke.
It's just a It's just a joke. It's just a joke. It's just a joke.
No, I also got sent what you're thinking about Tequila Sunset,
which is different, okay? I'm sorry. What you What you got sent
is different. This is all jokes. This is all jokes.
We're having a joking fun time where I also got sent this streamable.
What is this? I think genocide of the Jews is totally based.
Why? Why? Dude.
Dude, you guys are crazy.
You guys are crazy. Feels ableist somehow.
Uh I don't know, man.
There's a lot. There's a lot to take in right now, okay?
Pesco needs to sit further away for the for the Roman to get
thrown up
The hand disappears too quickly, okay? I think genocide of the
Jews is totally based. You guys are so up. I didn't make this,
by the way. People in my community didn't make this, by the Somebody
from a different community made this, okay? I'm not taking I'm
not taking the fall for this. This is bull
This is bull This is bull
I'm not taking the fall for this, okay? [__] that.
That, okay?
issue is, you don't need to look that
This is Connor's community making these things. They're trying
to convince Pesco to come over to the groper side, okay?
Are you a stupid person? No, I I do need to look it up. You don't
need to look that up.
Because you're you're you're trying You're trying to dunk on
me right now, and you're the one actually
So, you just tried to fact-check me in real time to say, "You're
wrong. Actually, from the framing we've had restrictive immigration
laws. And what you just pulled up to try to dunk on me is a total
slight of hand, which are the naturalization laws restricting
to a given race, which has nothing to do with what I'm talking
about or what you purport to be talking about, which aren't restrictions
on naturalization, restrictions on immigration." Uh this isn't
even like relevant to the original conversation, but I'll read
it for you. It's fine. Uh the first you this is an AI overview.
Okay. Pisco needs to remain calm, okay?
I don't mind AI overviews, but as we experienced earlier with
the whole thing about putting ships together modularly, which
does happen to some extent, okay? It does happen. That is how
they build them. But with that one company being like, "This
is the way we build ships. This is the way uh it's not always
the best. The AI overview is not always the best, okay? You should
be I would never call somebody wrong and then say "According
to this AI overview, right?" I don't think that you you haven't
earned the ability to go like, "Well, you kind of lied about
this according to this AI overview." Do you know what I mean?
You could say if you're both interested in something, you could
say, "I found this AI overview. Do you want me to read it?" But
like to go, "You're wrong according to this AI overview." So,
the first US immigration law was the Naturalization Act of 1790,
which established the first uniform rules of US citizenship,
allowing free white persons who resided in the US for 2 years
and showed good moral character to become citizens, also granting
citizenship to their children under 21 and children born abroad
to citizens. This >> Dude, this is like I don't know what
this is. its ability to regulate naturalization was limited to
white Europeans and set the stage for future and more restrictive
immigration policies. Also, before you freak out and start screaming
and like virtue signaling to your chat, Would you say that a
residency requirement has something to do with
No. People who weren't born in America, who had to live in America
for a certain amount of time and couldn't become citizens without
living in America for a certain amount of time.
Would you say they did an act before? Possibly. Where did they
come from? How did they spawn in?
has nothing to do with >> That's the not the the hang on.
That's >> immigration? Hang on. So, residency requirements
for purposes of naturalization doesn't have to do with
Immigration Restrictive immigration Who do you think is being
naturalized after they've
How do these [__] spawn in? That's different. That's
different. The laws The laws I'm talking You think it's They're
I mean, they're technically different. Yeah, honestly,
Pisco just says there's like no immigration laws defining the
country as like totally open borders. I would say that that point
is fine. Wait, hold on. That maybe is where he should go. Like
you're using this to disprove Pisco's claim that there were just
open borders before whatever time. Not Hart-Celler, but there's
something else in the 1900s, I think. I forget when the first
law that he referenced was. Wasn't Hart-Celler, though. Um
I would say Pisco is correct in that it basically was open borders.
That's probably about correct. That like they didn't really check
people that hard. They realistically probably just had the use
had use for like any kind of labor that would come to the country,
right? Americans who have always lived in the United States I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GOT THIS FROM I don't know I don't
know I don't know if you got this I don't I don't know if you
got this from Destiny where you do this word association. So,
you do a word association of immigration. Yeah, when you know
what I'm talking about here. What we're talking about are people
traveling to a place to live there permanently. And in the context
of residency requirements for naturalization, that's No, no,
no. That's Residency is not known as immigration. Someone can
be a resident for their entire life. in order to live someplace
per
But hold on. Them moving to that place is not blocked. So, we're
talking about legal immigrants. They're not citizens, right?
Like in the context of today, they would just be legal immigrants.
They would have some paperwork. There just wasn't paperwork to
move there to to move into the country, right? So, you're like
a legal It would be like getting a visa to come to America. You're
not a citizen, you don't get to vote, but you could become a
citizen if you lived in America for a certain amount of time.
Right? That is kind of a slight of hand. I don't really think
about these concepts very much, so I wouldn't have thought about
it. Pisco does think about these concepts a lot because he's
uh I think he wanted to be like an immigration lawyer, right?
>> Yeah, if if what's that what you just said? If you what?
If you move that >> Okay, all right. All right. So, all
right. So, so Are there Would you call that
the proof of is that by saying that there's naturalization pipe
pipelines or naturalization pathways, and they want to block
certain people's naturalization, doesn't it actually imply like
directly that
their immigration is allowed?
That there wasn't a restriction on their immigration? That they
could be there legally then you but you would block them from
naturalization and then from
Like the implication is there, right? A law that governs their
naturalization without governing their moving in, then that sort
of implies directly
Yeah, more or less directly that immigration is allowed. >> to
just completely demolish you. Can you be a resident in the Can
you be born in this country? At that time, could you be born
in this country Oh, I I think I do think that there was no birthright
citizenship at this point, right? Birthright gets added
>> and not be a citizen of the United States?
Yeah. Okay. Uh that is that was true back then. So, you could
be a resident
I think I think Pisco doesn't hasn't thought about that or he's
not seeing that. But I do think that that's basically implied
by the fact that you have a naturalization law with no immigration
laws in place. >> never lived anywhere else but the United
States and be subject to the naturalization laws, couldn't you?
Sorry, you're going to have to ask that again. I was doing something.
They're different concepts. Immigration relates to people coming
into the country to live there permanently. Now, residency requirements
apply both to those kinds of people, but also other types of
people. And so, what you're trying to do here is dodge what it
was an enormous blunder on your part, which is to try to fact-check
me on what I meant as though I were wrong by your AI summaries.
So, why don't we just Why don't you just grant me my point?
>> your audience? Does your audience do Do you Do you have
like Andrew Wilson's liberal audience? Like do they Do they
I think Oh, man. I think I want to copy-paste this and listen
here.
Wait, what's the timestamp of my stream?
So, we should get a timestamp for my stream for right now and
send it to Connor so he can hear my argument about why it's not
immigration.
Cuz I think that's actually the solution to their issues. I don't
know why Yeah.
Anyway. So, why don't we just Why don't you just grant me my
point? >> an argument to saying like, "I the way I was
disrespectful to Andrew Do Do you Do you have like Andrew Wilson's
liberal audience? Like Do they Do they say like what because
because this is something I'm just going to be disrespectful
to you the same way I was disrespectful to Andrew Wilson. Do
Do Does halfway through an argument to saying like, "I DEMOLISHED
YOU. I ANNIHILATED YOUR BUTT HOLE WITH THIS ARGUMENT." Do you
Do you find like a bunch of like in your CHAT BEING LIKE, "YEAH,
YOU DID IT." >> WAS AMERICA Was America Was America open
Pod, Connor's doing a dangerously good job at rhetoric. It's
almost like there's a intelligent human being inside of there.
Like this is actually a good way to deal with somebody who is
doing that, who's just like signaling, right?
I think he's been watching a lot of my content talking about
the the tone indicators.
He's He's literally calling out a tone indicator right now, right?
I will say basically every audience is susceptible to this. Every
audience is enough to fall for this. You just say you won and
people will think you won. Even people in Connor's audience.
Not joking. You're not going to lie. You're not going to lie.
You're not going to lie. You're not going to lie. >> was
in 1875 and 1870s, do you dispute
And 1870s, do you dispute that?
Yeah, I I I dispute it. >> Name Okay, what's one restrictive
immigration law?
I would say that residency applies to immigrants and therefore
it's an immigration law. >> Oh, okay. So,
so let me just change the wording. We can show We can show who's
working Yes, they're separate.
I think I do think Connor just genuinely doesn't understand cuz
it does feel a little concerning or it does feel a little confusing.
When you first started talking about it, I was on the other side
of this and then I had to think about it. And I will say if you
immediately become this aggressive with somebody, they're going
to have a hard time thinking about it and taking you like in
good faith, I think.
So, I do like the idea that Pisco's losing his patience with
people who aren't engaging directly. I do think he should also
try to temper that with people who are going to be a little slower.
Is Connor's I don't even know I think I think most people would
have a hard time figuring out what they're talking about here.
Like being able to go back and analyze what they were just saying
and and really thinking about it when someone's getting this
aggressive >> concepts? Yes, they're separate. divorced
as oil and water? They're They're They're They're separate. So,
let's let's just They are separate. As divorced as oil and water?
Not quite, but close,
right? Like what if literally
the US could have the US has naturalization or maybe they don't.
What if the US just imposed imposed naturalization quotas and
said, "But you can just move here. Like it's fine. But but there
will be quotas on who we naturalize. We won't naturalize any
of the browns or blacks. Okay, we'll only naturalize the whites.
But if you want to move here and work here without the right
to vote, you're fine to do so." Would Connor be okay with that?
Would he consider that preserving the heritage American [__]
I don't think so. >> who's playing word games. Let's show
who's playing word games. Do you agree that America was open
borders until
No. Oh, what were the restrictive immigration laws that prevented
people from entering into the country physically? Uh I I would
say I don't know what the laws on the books were, but I would
say that Native Americans were allowed >> How would you
know? >> territory was actually pretty well defined during
the time of the 13 colonies. Native Americans were not prohibited
within the borders of the United States. So so so wait wait hang
on. The question is were were there restrictive laws that prevented
people from entering into the country physically until the 1870s?
I asked that question and your answer was Native Americans were
allowed to leave the reservations. Now, can you understand why
that is Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait He just He did just
say something like
He basically said no, there's no restrictions on Indians.
Wait, were there any like restrictive immigration laws? Well,
there were no restrictions on Indians.
Sorry, at that point I'd be like
You want me to hit you, don't you? You want me to hit you, don't
you, Connor? You really want me to hit you right now. I don't
really want to do it, but you kind of want me to and it's weird.
Connor Connor Connor Connor Connor, let me talk, okay? You said
that you said that it was well defined. Connor, let me talk,
okay? You said that you said that it was well defined or that
natives me talk, okay? You said that I need the right frame.
I need the right frame. I don't do it. or that natives
That's actually way better. where their lands were. You said
that and then you said they were allowed to leave their lands.
Now, can you understand why that was the dumbest [__]
answer? Wait, didn't he say there were no restrictions allowed
into the borders of the United States. Okay, so it it's Oh, that's
the opposite of I'm pretty sure that's the opposite of what Connor
said. He just spoke again. >> that the native lands that
they these people were prevented from entering into the United
States and you would consider that their tribal lands were not
part of the United States of America?
At that time, yeah.
>> Wait a second. So, are you under the impression that
tribal lands under American law do not are not part of the geographical
territory of the United
I think he's saying at the time, which I have no idea when I've
got no idea when treaties are signed, when the Trail of Tears
happens. I don't know any of that history. I don't They don't
teach that in Canada.
I I have no idea, so it's really difficult to say. I think this
is a point anyway, but in the er That's like
I'm pretty sure at this time around 1790 or whatever, I'm pretty
sure if if that was at before the Trail of Tears, weren't Indians
just like straight up scalping [__] Weren't they
like cutting the hair off of people? Cutting yours off and [__]
Trail of Tears happened under Jackson. And if I were American,
that would give me a good solid understanding of the timeline.
I think Andrew Jackson is a founder. I think that's got to be
close to the founding of the country, so maybe that is around
that time. The 18th and 17th century or whatever, Native American
territories were not considered a part of the United States.
Okay, so Just just so you get that you're aware. Just so that
you're aware about the state of Native American land. It is true
that native lands aren't subject to the jurisdiction
of the United States.
I think Pisco's talking about now. So, it's a different set of
sovereigns at issue, but it is part of United States land. It's
part of the United States territory. Do you understand? Like
right now, for example, >> You're You're saying that west
of Appalachia, the United States was claiming that territory
as its own? >> Wait
a second. Wait a second. Wait a second. Wait wait a second. Wait
a second. Not if it's outside the country. Not if it's outside
America's land. YOU DIDN'T SAY THAT.
You didn't say that. In case your audience is I'll explain it
to you, okay? So, Pisco asked the question, did the United States
have restrictive
immigration laws prior to 18 whatever the [__] 70s?
And I brought up Native Americans as being people who were prohibited
from freely traveling within the United States of
And I'm finding a law prohibiting Native Americans from traveling
within the the Commonwealth of the United States as early as
and I almost guarantee you that I can find laws probably before
the existence of the >> What's What's the law called? What's
the law called? What's the law called?
What's the law called? What's the
What's the law called?
So so so so no, we're we are not moving off this topic, Connor,
cuz what you tried to do was dishonest and you know it was dishonest.
You know what you were trying to do was dishonest. 15 minutes,
so I might have to wrap up in a second. Connor, you know what
you just did was completely dishonest. And me being upset or
angry about it? Yes. Yes, it
Connor is pulling like the Joe Biden card right now. He's like
getting to feel a little eepy. He's a little worn >> was.
Yes, it 100% was. I'm not even angry. Listen, what you might
not be angry. What you tried to do just then was chicken [__]
And you're playing word games now and you're going to produce
to me the law that you say you found regarding Native Americans.
Okay. >> law called?
first
US law about Native Americans [laughter] and No, you said you
had a law from the 1830s. I did. Wait, where'd you get that from?
What did What were you looking at? AI?
Yeah, let me find the 1830 one. The Indian Removal Act of 1830
was the one that I pulled up. Indian Removal Act 1830. This is
Wikipedia. >> do like
English colonial
against Native Americans.
The law as described by Congress provided for an exchange of
lands with the Indians residing in any of the states or territories
and for their removal west of the river Mississippi.
And you call this a restrictive immigration law? Can you explain
in what sense it is? Where are the Where is the provision that
restricts Yeah, Native Americans are not freely allowed to travel
into the territory of the United States and if they do so, they'll
be deported. >> Where Where is that? Where is that?
Were they deported or were they just
Didn't you just read it? No, that's not what that said. That
Read it again out
I read a Wikipedia summary and it said
the following. The Indian Removal Act as described by Congress
provided quote for an exchange of lands with the Indians residing
in any of the states or territories. You agree that's different
that they can't come in? Agree yes or
Uh sorry, you'd have to state it again. I'm reading things as
well.
>> Wait wait wait Connor, I'm not going to have you read
things and not listen to me when you were having a discussion.
When you stop for a moment you say reread something. So, I'm
going to stop. >> You're asking me to find you >> Connor,
no no no no no stop. We We already have one. We have the You
You've provided one and we're going to do step by step. So, this
law is what we're looking at right now. You don't need to look
for anything else. We found the law. So, pay attention to me
when I'm Well, I also found one in 1763. You go 1763 is predates
the United States. Just so you're aware. Okay? So, in the 1830
Removal Act, you're listening to me, right?
is an exchange of lands with the Indians residing in any of the
states or territories. Is that preventing them from entering
into the country? No. Okay. And the next part is removal west
of the river river Mississippi. Is that preventing entry into
the United States?
I would presume absolutely. That's not a restrictive immigration
law. That's a removal law, right? Wait, so so hold on hold on.
So, you I don't like that. I don't like that one now. That feels
like Oh, it's like dude, what's a restrictive immigration law
then? Like like literally setting up like a minefield all across
the southern border? Like like what is a restrictive immigration
law? Oh, if you're in then I don't know. I literally don't know.
think that the sovereign Native Americans who lived between the
Mississippi and the East >> I'm asking you a question.
I'm asking
you a question.
I am asked Connor, I'm asking you a question. Is a law providing
for It I feel like all immigration laws would be removal laws
back then because you just wouldn't have the technology. You
wouldn't have the ability to cover the borders, right? Like it
would just all be Yeah, it just sounds like basically you're
playing on the fact that there isn't really like a border patrol
set up. It would be totally infeasible to do so back then. You've
moved You've moved on >> I AM NOT NO NO CONNOR, we had
open borders. Open borders means that Native Americans could
travel freely within the United States of America, but you're
just wrong. Connor Connor Connor Connor, pause. We're just taking
this so slowly. There's not going to be any bad faith here. Don't
worry. So, you agree that the exchange of lands is not a restrictive
immigration law in that it doesn't prevent people from entering
into the United States, correct yes or And is a law providing
for the removal of certain persons a restrictive immigration
law in that it prevents people from coming into the United States,
yes or no? Yes. Okay, so Just say just say no, but I would say
you being like automatically removed the second you're detected
by anybody who can remove you, like you're an illegal
You are there illegally. Your presence is not wanted. By definition,
if you are violating the law by entering the country, that is
a restrictive immigration law, I would say.
Uh that Yeah, it's We're just talking about different things
because I grant you at the founding of the country there was
a thing called the Alien Act. Remember the Sedition Alien and
Sedition Acts? The Alien Acts does provide for removal of certain
people, but that's not what we're talking about, Connor. We're
talking about restrictive immigration laws. Laws that prevent
the entry into the country. Do you understand what I'm saying?
I can't hear you. Sorry, needed to click the mute button. Laws
that make it illegal to enter the country. What you're saying
is what you're saying is because because I I think that anybody
with a functioning brain and probably a brain stem could see
how flatly absurd this is.
Well, I mean technically
technically the Romans did the German border. They built a whole
like set of walls. They set up They did set up some places. They
set up
essentially outpost all across the Danube to prevent the Germans
from coming in, right? Right?
So, it's like there are cases, but it's like that was the only
empire technically like technologically and like manpower wise
and organization like logistics wise capable of doing that. Like
it was basically denied to every everybody else.
Yeah, I sorry I'm And I do have to go in a second, but I'm happy
to continue this tomorrow. So crazy, dude. Or the next day, or
the next day, or Uh so, what you're saying is there was the Commonwealth
of Virginia, right? It was It was a state that was a member of
the 13 colonies. >> I didn't mention that. >> And
then And a Native American uh Lakota, Dakota,
Sioux, Cheyenne, Apache, whatever, they show up to the first
you know, they show up to the borders of the Commonwealth of
Virginia and there's a constable
who's responsible for that
And so the constable >> any of this. I didn't say any of
this. He goes Oh yeah, Native Americans, go ahead, go right on
in. We're open
We have no laws about Native Americans. You can go right into
the Commonwealth of Virginia. So Connor, you agree I didn't say
any of this?
That's what the definition of an open border would be, Pisko.
>> wait wait wait no Connor Connor, you understand I didn't
say any of this? You just said this. Yeah, yeah, I'm using this
as an example >> So what when you said that the United
States was open borders. Do you understand how Do you understand
Do you understand how much of a It's not laughable. It's It's
It's It's not laughable. It is not laughable. No, I'm I'm I'm
going to So So So Connor
Connor Connor Connor
Connor Connor Connor Connor Yes, they could travel freely to
the United States. Under the law under the law of the United
States, that is true.
Including Native Americans, including Africans and some of whom
were brought here against their will. But let's just see very
quickly, I'm not going to be distracted. What you just did was
so slimy as to be indistinguishable from bad faith. What you
just gave was a fact pattern in which What? You think all of
these Another destiny tactic. If all of a sudden we had a thousand
Native Americans show up all of a sudden to the Commonwealth
that a constable looking at them under the authority of the Commonwealth
of Virginia wouldn't say
This is accurate. I love it spiritually.
It is not going to stop the uh the This is not going to stop
not going to stop the people who are characterizing him in bad
faith at all. Not that they would stop anyway.
It is so gay. Do you understand how bad This is how you This
is how you have to Like these are valid points and it's like
I have to sit here and like argue, well, is this smart for him
with like a literal terrorist ready to sabotage everything he's
working towards? Is this really the white Is it smart to speak
the truth when that truth is about somebody who has a large audience?
They have been They have a large audience and a group of dedicated
doxers they've seemed perfectly willing to deploy whenever they
feel threatened in any way. Is this Is this really the tactic
you want to take, Pisko? Do you really want to threaten the terrorists?
Okay. You're cutting people's heads off. You really want to threaten
these people? Seems like not a good idea, man. >> bad faith
of representation that was? Yeah, yeah. Do you understand how
bad faith of representation that was? Can you explain why you
SAID THAT? YOU'RE NOT [clears throat] IT'S [__]
NO, ARGUMENTS. NO, NO, NO. The question isn't would someone do
something? Would someone say something? WOULD SOMEONE BE UPSET
ABOUT SOMETHING?
>> WHAT WAS THE COMMONWEALTH? WHAT WAS THE What was the
question, Connor?
Well, I mean I'm about to read the Alien and Sedition Act. Yeah,
the Alien and Sedition Act provided for the removal of persons
deemed to be alien for uh
And also um and and that's currently what we're doing with the
Alien Enemies Act. That's removal.
Okay. So So you're saying up until uh So So what what a what
a constable would do or what a federal representative would do
is they would say, "Welcome in Native Americans, blacks, Frenchmen,
and >> YOU JUST DID IT AGAIN. LOOK HOW BAD FAITH YOU ARE.
LOOK LOOK HOW
LOOK AT HOW BAD faith for you
I don't even think this argument is good from Pisko to say like
all there were no immigration laws. Like literally scientific
progress was the all the only immigration law you needed, right?
That's it.
It's just scientific progress. That's
1790s, yeah, it's like really difficult to travel here. It's
literally travel to It Sorry, it's difficult to travel within
America. Like literally sometimes you just die traveling within
America.
Let alone coming from a different country, okay?
You don't even need immigration laws. So it's like something
that shouldn't even be discussed. It doesn't even matter. Literally
didn't matter to the broader
Look at how bad faith you are. They're invited into the country.
Then maybe about 20 minutes later some other federal guy goes,
This is insane. You're a class of person that needs to be removed
from this country. So So So no. Wait. Wait. Connor, did you think
but there's absolutely a law about taking them out. Connor, did
you hear me
that I was representing that the American
Shut the [__] up.
Did I say that they were inviting people in? You can just answer
that clearly. No. No. So why did you just do that hypothetical?
You think everyone would say, "Come in." And why did you say
that if not that you
No, what is What do you think
Wait Wait Wait Wait What What DO YOU THINK OPEN BORDER MEANS?
Wait Wait So do you think that open borders is saying that there
are no restrictive laws on entering the country, or do you think
that open borders means everybody come on in and actively inviting
and courting people to come into the country? Which of those
two things better represents the term open borders? I think the
first one is probably law. I think the second one is the culture.
>> So when you were referring Uh I See, this is the thing
when you get aggressive, right? is
Connor's literally like dancing and Connor doesn't need to be
dancing.
I think this is just a misread. I don't I don't think Pisko needs
to change that much. I think it's a misread though on when to
get aggressive and when not to be aggressive.
I think he just needs to calibrate that a little bit better.
I think this conversation could have been really easy without
being this aggressive. I don't mind that he's like trying it
out. He's trying to get more aggressive and just see how it works.
I think that's like good to do. I think this is a little too
much. I I understand like we don't really love Connor here. It's
like a little too much cuz I think the conversation could have
moved forward and
didn't have to get stalled out here at all. And it literally
doesn't matter if the country had open borders before. This is
conservative thing like oh we can only Oh, no no no. The It's
yeah, it's basically arguing Connor's
But they got stuck on some pedantry.
Which like I'm fine with Pisko. Here's the thing is sometimes
the pedantry is important. Like Pisko laid out a real thing where
he's like, "Hey, you're trying to say this is an immigration
law right now. I don't like that." He can call it bad faith,
but I don't think this was bad faith. Yeah.
Like Yeah, I don't think this was bad faith on Connor's part.
I think Connor's
I think the way I described it that like, "Hey, obviously there's
no there's no prevention of like them moving here, working, living
generally in society, but there is a law against naturalization."
That kind of implies that if this is the only law standing at
the time that moving there, working there, owning property there,
a whole bunch of like literally just building your life there
isn't something that's disallowed. Yeah. referring to open borders.
And when I ask you, isn't it true America had open borders until
Hang on a second. Last question and you You have to keep doing
This is This is beneath you, Connor. What Your behavior here
it it is all ego driven. It You could just because you lost on
a SINGLE POINT >> WITH ME? NO, IT'S CRAZY. THIS IS BAD
FAITH. THIS IS A DESTINY TACTIC. NO, WHAT YOU JUST SAID What
you What you just What you just do as a I'll I'll I'll explain.
Wait. Wait. What What you just Wait. Connor Connor CONNOR CONNOR
CONNOR CONNOR CONNOR CONNOR Connor Connor Connor Connor Connor,
stop. Connor
I think Connor's just
This is See, I always The problem with me is
I always err on the other side of this and then I end up walking
in circles with complete
who are never willing to actually have a conversation with me.
And if I just started doing this earlier on, I would feel like
I wasted my time a lot less. So like I have the opposite problem
where I will see like sure signals that somebody is being a totally
bad faith They are like trying to dance around and and get some
terrible point out, right? But I don't think that's what's happening
here. I'm saying the same >> Connor, stop. So the reason
why I said that of you is because you totally mischaracterized
my point and did a straw man. The straw man was that I was construing
the founding generation to be like, "We don't care about race.
Everyone come on in. Every We love peoples. Come and enjoy our
blueberries." That was the straw man that you did. And you're
like, "This is what you actually believe?" That's bad faith,
Connor. That's bad faith. And it's almost like
No, it's not. Uh no, it's not. You know that cuz technology is
the barrier. They don't need a law. Come on, man.
It It Wait, there is no logical extension there. You can have
it. Wait Wait Wait Wait Wait, there is no logical extension there.
There is no Wait There is no Wait There is There is no logical
extension there whatsoever.
No, no, don't worry. I'll explain it. So So here here's what
happened is I brought up Heart-Cellar Act as a revolution in
the way that we approach immigration policy.
The the demography of the United States of America. You were
like, "That's a groper talking." >> It is. That's a right-wing
talking point. And then I said, "Okay, well, if it's descriptively
real, who gives a shit?" And then you said, "Well, it's not descriptively
real. The United States had open borders for the first century
of its existence." And then I conversation. Wait. You're not
even tracking the
our Ooh, the Constitution.
Pisko's misspeaking a lot. Connor just rattled him. Now he's
going to slowly disconnect. He's slowly like getting his wife
to dial the modem like bandwidths down so that he eventually
gets disconnected from the call. Alien and sedition >> Crazy.
or >> Indian Removal Act of the 1830
or whatever act that I cited to you that was like 1875.
I do I actually do fully believe Connor could be a groper. Connor
could be
Connor could be a communist.
You could convince Connor to be a communist for sure. All you'd
have to do
is basically figure out how to write a very compelling story
about how space communists rode to the rescue of space fascists
and they saved humanity, okay? Human space communists rode to
the rescue of human space fascists and they ended up winning
the day, okay? Against some alien horde that was going to All
That's all you'd have to do, okay? And then he'd be a little
bit on their side and then you'd have to write really cool lore
about the space communists, okay?
That did that basically showed them like tweaking their society
slightly, okay? I don't know if he's into Wow, this is before
the K. >> Um it'd be It's pretty clear that we did care
about the ethno-religious groups of the people that we allowed
into our country. >> talked about that.
I never WAIT, I NEVER TALKED ABOUT ETHNO-RELIGIOUS. WAIT, I never
talked about ethno-religious. Connor, Connor, Connor, I didn't
talk about ethno-religious. I didn't say anything about that.
I wasn't representing that I Wait, I I didn't represent that
America didn't care about its ethno-religious
>> at some point. You said it after you said immigration
was a wall that people wanted to tear down. You said ethno-religious
after showing what you actually care about cuz you're a [__]
groper. That's what you said. I never made a representation.
I need you to say this. I never made a representation that the
Americans didn't care about the ethno-religious background. [__]
I don't like disagreeing with Pisco on this, but I do disagree
with him.
I'll see if I can wake up early enough to call into his stream,
I'll call into his stream to argue about this a little Cuz I
do think he's actually getting this wrong and I do think Connor
is like I think I assume Connor has my point where it's like
I just don't know how important that is and it might actually
be important. We don't have good examples of a country like a
multi a truly multicultural multi-ethnic country that has no
dominating ethnic majority or religious group majority that works.
We just don't have it, right? We don't have a large-scale example
of this. Every single Western democracy that exists is not like
this.
And so how important is it? We did it was called late Rome and
it collapsed. Yeah, but the golden age of Rome was with literally
like literal swarthoids running it, not Italians. Never forget
that cacophonies. You're never going to Rome check me cuz I know
that the golden age of Rome was ushered in Okay, first by Augustus,
but then the five good emperors, none of those names was [__]
Roman. None of those names was [__] Italian, okay?
Golden age of Rome was unified? Um it was unified under like
a nationalist sentiment, like a oh the empire is great sentiment.
It wasn't unified under ethnic sentiments. Hadrian and Trajan
both from the Iberian Peninsula. The height of the Roman Empire
was under little little like Hispanic rats. Hispanic like mutts,
okay? From the provinces.
That's it. That's facts, man. people coming into the country.
That is an absurd thing that I just never said.
I say that, but um
I say that. But obviously I think Trajan and Hadrian are probably
both great emperors.
And I don't say that about Hadrian because he genocided the entirety
of the Jews, okay? I say that because he managed a great empire
and a lot of twinks, okay? Of course the founding generation
distrusted Catholics, distrusted all sorts of groups. So you're
Why?
>> a unrestricted
or non-existent immigration policy. Open border actually means
white Americans caring about the residency and ethno-religious
background of the people we allowed into our country. What are
you talking about?
But I would say I would say with the Roman Empire
how did that work? That's like conquest, so it's also a different
thing. It's not people entering this Yeah, and they had slavery,
the economic conditions are way different. I think it's very
very very >> No, wait a second. No, I Open borders to me
are the lack of restrictions, legal restrictions, on entering
into the country. That's what open borders means. No No There's
no rules for people coming in. That's what open borders is. Do
you agree or disagree?
Connor Connor should have just bit the bullet on yes, ethno-religious
majority or ethnis ethno-religious plurality is my concern.
mention of your statement. And then just take it Pisco calling
him a groper repeatedly so he can actually talk about it. Native
Americans show up to the Commonwealth of Virginia and they're
allowed in. So allowed in. When you say allowed in, there they
there is no law that requires their them to be stopped, that
prevents them from entering. That's the actual Yes, that is what's
going on here. There is no restrictive immigration law. By the
way, there's no internal checks within the United States either
from from a customs perspective, but there were no restrictive
immigration laws in the United States. Now, does that mean that
you couldn't find me an example of some hundred natives crossing
where some constable gets a band of people to push them the [__]
out? No, that's not what it means. Does that mean that I'm saying
there were no removal laws under the United States? No, I'm saying
only what I mean, which is there were no restrictive immigration
laws preventing the entry of peoples into the United States.
Does that mean that nothing was ever done with vigilantes, that
there were ever like bad constables or whatever? That's your
straw man. That's your
Because you can't handle the fact that I'm right. I I think you
have autism, but I'm about >> This is so crazy, dude. 30
minutes overtime, but >> we'll we'll talk tomorrow. We'll
talk tomorrow, but Yeah, we'll talk tomorrow, but seriously,
for just for today, I love you. I do want to say I love you.
I love you, too. I I I love you. I I think you got your panties
in a twist. You're going a little crazy, but that's >> Connor,
Connor, Connor, Connor, Connor, I love you. I am going to say
this seriously though, for today go [__] yourself.
Mic drop moment.
Did I Listen, that's a little I believe Pisco will get teased
for this a little bit, okay? He's got to stand up to the teasing.
You got to practice it. You got to practice being like a harsh
Listen, you don't become a stone-cold psychopath overnight, okay?
And that's probably what you got to be. You don't become a stone-cold
psychopath overnight. Sometimes you got to kill a couple dogs
first, okay? You put Connor down there. Now tomorrow he'll put
him down again. He's He's getting there. He's got to psych himself
up, okay? He's got to psych himself up. Uh
I think I think it was too much. I think it was But I get where
he's coming from. He's like playing around with trying that out.
Yeah. I get it. It just It also didn't feel quite right for how
patient he normally is. Maybe it could be the stark contrast
from the normal way he deals with
I don't I I straight-up like don't really have The criticisms
are pretty light. The criticisms are pretty light,
To be honest with you.
Jesus Christ. Can you imagine the balls of that guy? Absolutely
deranged.
And you see the bad faith tactics right away where he's referencing
a naturalization law using AI to try to claim that I'm saying
something that I never said. A, that there weren't restrictions
on
Oh, dude, NHH is stuck in my head. Damn, why do we do that? >> fathers
didn't care about the ethnic makeup of people coming in or the
religious makeup of people coming Of course absurd things I never
signed on to.
C, that like there couldn't be situations in which individual
law enforcement officers of given states could have taken some
action against a roving band of people coming into the country
or coming into their state. Absolutely unhinged.
Clear bad faith, clear lies.
That said, I'll stop him again.
Oh, bunch of um bunch of totally bad faith actors in the chat
here, I see.
Getting cheered on by bad faith actors trying to manipulate him
into
Don't do it, Pisco. Don't do it. Um if I wake up early enough
tomorrow and he's doing call-ins, I would think about calling
into his stream and just having this conversation.
Cuz I do I do think that you can believe the things Connor believes.
Maybe. I don't know exactly how important he thinks ethno-majority
like ethno-religious majority is. I cuz I don't
I'm basically uh I'm of the opinion where I think it might be
Will he get on? Yeah, Pisco would have me on, I'm pretty sure.
He's like not I don't think he's the kind of person who really
thinks you disable the stuff. Will you reveal your identity?
Probably not.
I think you can have the ethno-religious
Will Pisco call you a groper? Almost certainly. If he's going
to call Connor a groper for this exact same point. Like I think
I have like probably more concern than the average liberal, significantly
more, that this wouldn't work, that I think like there probably
is something important to an ethno-religious majority, like an
I think an ethnic majority more than a religious one, but I think
a religious one could work, maybe.
Kind of how it works in Israel. They have like a shared background
in Israel even though they've got like different races there.
Yeah. Ethnic is a different definition than rest of word, by
the way. What time do you usually get up and what time does Pisco
stream at? I I'm just getting up late right now. That's the issue.
That is the issue. Okay, I think I think that's it. Just crazy.
And here's another thing. I immediate I can smell the groper
talking points right away. They talk about the Hart-Celler Act.
All the gropers do. As the foundations of the like ethnic betrayal
of the United States. They don't
about the INA or the Hart-Celler
Well, I would say that the like Okay, the Hart-Celler Act I I
don't think defining it as like an ethnic betrayal makes any
sense, right? But it is almost certainly the source of the change
of demographics in the United States or it is like a Basically
like you could use the Before the Hart-Celler Act, you could
if you could if you cared about this, have ways of preventing
this from happening. But, I think they just decided they want
wanted more labor in the country, right? Almost certainly. They're
just like I I think this is blocking like labor imports, right?
I'd have to look at it. I don't know the history behind the Hart-Celler
Act, either. But, I just don't I don't feel like I have any Most
things that happen in terms of laws are done from an economic
standpoint, right? Anything like immigration, I don't think that's
done from a moral
It wasn't about labor? What was it about? I'd have to go look
and see what people are saying at the time. Some video started
playing. Okay, we use this already with major use for farm workers.
We use visas already with major use for farm workers. It's about
specifically ending European dominated migration. Um
Sure, find me Lyndon B. Johnson saying that specifically. Or
are you going to say you can infer that because that's what happened?
Cuz that's not an argument. Find me Lyndon B. Johnson or like
a popular politician, somebody in the Senate in the House at
that time, who's arguing that this is the goal is to end European
immigration in the United States. Cuz if I know one thing about
people in the 1960s,
them was racist, okay? Them was racist. You think I Do we really
think that they went out and said, "Hey, we're going to import
a whole bunch of swarthoids, browns, blacks into this country.
You guys are cool with that, right?" Do we really think they
did that or did they have like other reasons for doing it and
you're just reading into it because the the outcome of it was
the ethnic
I guess like the change of the ethnic makeup of the country.
They would have I assume we'd have somebody on the record saying
that was the goal if that was the
Like some politician would be on record saying that's the goal,
no? Yeah, see here it is. The output of the machine is its purpose.
Okay. Just like that Oh, hold on. What was the What was the
uh thalidomide. So, like the goal of the pharmaceutical company
that made thalidomide was to kill babies, right? They just wanted
to kill a bunch of babies cuz the output of the machine is its
purpose. So, they explicitly wanted to pretend they were producing
a nausea drug, but they actually made a drug to just kill a bunch
of babies in the womb. Cuz that's what they wanted to do. We
can infer their intent from the output. Is an obviously ridic
thing to say. You Yes, you could be convinced of anything if
that is your belief. Literally no such thing as mistakes. It's
not a good way to operate in the world. Oh, so in that case,
all of Britain is a machine to spread Islam. Yeah, it's like
Yeah, you could validate literally any belief you want. If the
company consistently made drugs that harm people, then maybe
it isn't
Where is the consistent harm? United States not continue to dominate
the entire world for like decades after that? I would say most
people weren't really complaining about immigration until what,
the 1990s, the 2000s?
I think into the 2000s, we're still not even really It's like
probably the 2000s is when they took our jobs are really popping
off.
Like outside of the just general idea that, "Hey, these people
are coming here and they're they're working." That,
They took our jobs. You know what I'm talking about? They took
our jobs.
Short-term economic benefit. I mean, immigration's always an
economic benefit. There's just There's other things to consider.
Is there really a shortage of labor in the United States right
now? I don't think there is. There's clearly not a shortage of
labor in the United States. There's a shortage of labor at the
prices people want to pay,
which is like borderline slave wages for a lot of jobs.
There is a shortage of labor for that. Yeah, that's true. I think
what One thing Trump did was he decided
I wouldn't care if they did this on every single thing, every
single product. That basically, if you sell a product for a certain
price in the
you have to sell it for that plus some allowance for transport
fees in the United States. That you can't sell any product somewhere
else in the world
for like five pennies on the dollar and then come to the US and
be like, "You You need to pay me $1,000 for this." Right? I sell
this in for like $20 over in this country, then I go to the US
and I'm like, "This is $1,000 now." I think they should have
laws on that. I think that
is okay. I think a lot of things start to change pretty quickly
if um if that's the case. That a lot of people are making a lot
more money off of the US system than they should be.
Again, I haven't thought about that. That's That's my reactionary
take. I've literally never looked into that. Could have really,
really, really horrific
I mean, I probably would have really bad downstream effects,
okay?
But, I'm just saying that like there's there's something going
on there where it's like we're going to import a ton of labor.
We're not going to be able to pay people. We're going to make
massive profits. And we're also going to ship a bunch of stuff
around the world and sell it for cheaper than we sell it to Americans.
Something's [__] there,
I smell something [__] up there. That's really [__]
up, okay? Something [__] up is happening. I don't
know what it is. Okay.
If you're going to globalize your labor, you're going to globalize
your labor, then globalize the supply demand curve,
Find a global supply demand price point. Or Americans are going
to make a law that you have to. It's literally required.
Anyway. Okay, I've
What a great rant at the end. I'm I'm literally half asleep,
okay? I love you guys. I'm going to be back tomorrow. Bye. Bye.
Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night.